GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE WILL CALL TO ORDER THE.
THE FIRST MEETING OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON NATURAL DISASTER
RESPONSE RECOVERY. AND
REBUILDING.
I LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
DISTINGUISHED PANELISTS THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US TODAY
WERE WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE YOUR EXPERTISE AND INPUT.
ON THIS ISSUE
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE SEASON WAS THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND COSTLY ON RECORD.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
ESTIMATES THAT THE FIRES BURNED
OVER ONE POINT THREE MILLION
ACRES DESTROYED APPROXIMATELY
TEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES.
THAT WERE LISTED AS PARTIAL
LOSSES
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN IS PART OF
HIS MAY BUDGET REVISED COMMITTED
TO SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. IN
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
WILDLIFE PREVENTION.
THE GOVERNOR HAS PLEDGED
ADDITIONAL NINETY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE FORCED
CARBON PLAN.
SUPPORT FORCED IMPROVEMENT IN
FIRE PREVENTION PROJECTS TO
REDUCE FUEL LOADS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM THE FIRES AND
POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO WATERSHEDS
AND COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE
ALREADY PROMISED ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING FOR FIRE FIGHTING
EFFORTS.
ALSO INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION IS THE TWELFTH AT
TWENTY NINE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLAR PROCREATION FOR DEBRIS
REMOVAL IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES TO WAIVE.
THE LOCAL MATCHES.
DESPITE THE TREMENDOUS
DESTRUCTION CALIFORNIA IS
RECOVERING TOGETHER WE REALLY WE
WE WILL REBUILD STRONGER. THAN
BEFORE AND.
WITH
THE THE BUDGET APPROPRIATIONS AS
WE SEE IN THE REVISION WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A WHOLE LOT MORE
WORK TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR CAT HOLE. AND
CAN RECOVER AND CAN BE BACK
BETTER THAN THEY WERE BEFORE I
WOULD LIKE TO NOW INTRODUCE MY
CO CHAIR AND DELIGHTED TO TO
INTRODUCE A SOME MEMBER MONIQUE
LIMON.
YES I REMEMBER.
THERE YOU GO THANK YOU SALLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND AND I THINK
YOU ALSO TO HAVE OUR COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A SOME MEMBER WALDRON
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR
CURRY. A IS WALKING AND NO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND WAS
JUST HERE. AYE I THINK OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE GONE THROUGH A
SERIES OF IMMENSE TRAGEDIES.
ONE AFTER THE OTHER AND IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT WE HAD.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST WILDFIRE
FOLLOWED BY THE TRAGEDY IN MONO
SETO.
BUT THERE ARE EFFORTS TO SECURE
FUNDING.
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE HAS
MENTIONED.
IN THE BUDGET TO HELP ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
BOTH RECOVER COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THE NATURAL DISASTERS AS
WELL AS PREVENT THEM FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE.
WITH THE CERTAINTY THAT.
.
A FIRE SEASON IS NOW A YEAR
ROUND SEASON THESE CHALLENGES
WILL NOT BE GOING AWAY.
RECOVERY WILL NOT BE EASY BUT
THROUGH THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY WILL
ADDRESS FORWARD THINKING
POLICIES AND FOCUS ON A
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
HELP US. DURING THESE CHALLENGES
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS WHO ARE HERE I THINK I
WE WILL HEAR FROM PANELISTS THAT
WILL PROVIDE BOTH A LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO A STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVE ON. SOME NOT ALL OF
THE ELEMENTS THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES FACE POST NATURAL
DISASTER ON AND TRAGEDY SO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR OF PRESENTERS IN
HEARING SOME INFORMATION. AND
AGAIN THINGS TO OUR COLLEAGUES
I'M WHO ARE THINKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
YEAR ROUND AS WELL.
AND WITHOUT WOULD ANY OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS EFFORTS DURING AS I WORK
VERY. HARD TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
AND I LOOK FOR TO.
LISTING TO SOME OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE PANELISTS TODAY AND LIKE
TO JUST MOVE FORWARD TO GET
GOING.
THIS WATER.
THANK YOU WELCOME IT'S A
PLEASURE TO SERVE ON THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE AND.
WE'RE GOING TO BE DISCUSSING A
LOT OF IMPORTANT ISSUES. WE KNOW
THAT THE FIRES AFFECTED US IN SO
MANY WAYS ALL ACROSS THE STATE
BOTH ARE IN ECONOMIC WAYS
INDIVIDUALS WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
ARE ENVIRONMENTS.
NOT TO MENTION THE REBUILDING
PROCESS AND EVERYTHING ELSE SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF THE FIRST PANEL IS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES WE
HAVE. TO DISCUSS THE PROGRESSION
OF THE REBUILDING PROCESS AND
CHALLENGES THAT LOCAL AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS HAVE EXPERIENCED.
AND.
IN YOU CAN COME ON UP AYE THE
FIRST PANELIST IS MICHAEL
THOMPSON THE ASSISTANT GENERAL
MANAGER. AT THE CINEMA COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY.
AND THAT WILL BE SPEAKING ABOUT
A VERY.
INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE OF
ISSUES THAT WE HAD NEVER
CONSIDERED.
.
INTEL LISTA SOCK CALAMITY.
AND THEN OUR NEXT PANELIST IS
JAMES QUIRK COUNTY SUPERVISOR
FOR THE FOURTH DISTRICT AT
CINEMA COUNTY IN IS ALSO HERE.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND WE'RE ALSO A PRIVILEGE TO
HAVE KNOWN AMIR SOTO I THE CEO.
OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA.
YOU KNOW IN ACTUALLY IF IF
ON.
I DON'T THINK AT THE MEMBERS
MIND TO JUST CONFERRED WITH MY
MY CO CHAIR WE HAVE THE VICE
MAYOR OF SANTA ROSA IF YOU LIKE
TO COME UP AND JOIN US THAT
BECAUSE.
MASTIC.
WITH MISTER THOMPSON.
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING US ALL IN FOR.
A CONVENING THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE. APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH TOM.
MORE THINGS BEFORE MACAO MIKE
THOMPSON SYSTEM JOURNAL MANAGER
WITH THE CINEMA COUNTY WATER
AGENCY.
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT.
THIS GOING ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES I KNOW OF PEOPLE ARE
FACING IN THE REBUILDING PROCESS
AND SOME OF THINGS.
THE DID A REFERENCE WE ALL SAID
ABOUT HOW WE REBUILD BETTER THAN
WE WERE BEFORE AND THAT'S REALLY
BEEN A BIG EMPHASIS ON SOMETHING
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON.
JUST AS A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND LIKE.
.
LIVED MOST OF MY LIFE AND AND
SOME COUNTING SANTA ROSA BUT IT
DID LIVE FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
ENTER A.
AND AND I KNOW.
ON DECEMBER FIFTH I WAS LOOKING.
FOLLOWING THE TRACK OF THE OF
THE THOMAS FIRE AND AND
UNFORTUNATELY MY BEST FRIEND
DOWN THERE IN THE AREA LOST
THEIR HOME.
AND SO I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
THEM AND WOULD MANY OF THEM I'VE
I'VE ASKED EXIT. DIE TALK TO
KAREN TODAY AND SAYS I'M
SPEAKING BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
WILL WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO TELL
THEM.
AND SHE HAD AT SOME SOME.
THE AND WOULD HAVE NOTICE WITH
REGARD TO THE THE CHALLENGES. A
LOT OF IT DEPENDS ON WHERE YOU
ARE IN YOUR JOURNEY.
WE IN CINEMA COUNTY WERE A
COUPLE MONTHS AHEAD OF. VENTURA
IN THE THAT THE JOURNEY OF MANY
OF THE PROPERTY OWNERS AND SO.
WHAT?
MY FRIEND KAREN SAID FIRST WELL
SHE WANTED ME TO PASS ON MY
APPRECIATION TO YOU ALL FOR THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON INSURANCE.
THE THE FACT THAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO GET SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THEIR ITEMIZED OF THEIR CONTENTS
WITHOUT HAPPENED ITEMIZED.
WAS HUGE.
.
I KNOW THAT FOR MANY FRIENDS
AFTER THEY LOST THEIR HOMES THEY
WERE.
YOU KNOW FINDING NEW PLACES TO
LIVE AND JUST THE WHOLE FACT OF
YOU LOST YOUR HOME YOU'RE LIVING
IN A HOUSE.
WHERE EVERY MOVEMENT TAKES
THOUGHT WERE LIKE?
WHERE WHY HOW DO WE GET TO THE
KITCHENWHERE DID I PUT WEARS
EVERYTHING PUT IT HITCHED CRISIS
MENTAL FATIGUE AND IN ADDITION
TO THAT? THEY WERE HAVING TO GO
THROUGH ITEMIZING EVERYTHING
THEY HAD LOST WHICH IS.
WHICH WAS TOP AND SO. JUST WANT
TO PASS ON FROM FOR MANY OF THE
APPRECIATION TO ALL OF YOU FOR.
ESSENTIALLY.
LEARNING FROM WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH IN CINEMA AND AND FIXING
THAT THE REGARD TO THAT MAY NOT
SEEM LIKE.
A LITTLE THING BUT IT WAS REALLY
HUGE TWO A LOT OF THE THE PEOPLE
I TALKED WITH JUST TO HAVE THAT
MENTAL SPACE AND IT. REALLY
HELPED THEM USE THAT ENERGY FOR
ELSEWHERE.
THERE WAS THE AND I'M SURE IF
YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT THE
CONCERNS ABOUT. PIC FOLKS BEING
PIT PROPERTY OWNERS BEING UNDER
INSURED THAT IS A VERY REAL
ISSUE WE HAD ONE OF OUR A WATER
AGENTS COLLEAGUES. ACTUALLY.
TWO DAYS BEFORE THE FIRE THEY
HAD.
GOTTEN THEIR DOCUMENTS AND
THEY'VE.
SUCCESSFULLY UPDATED INCREASE
OUR FIRE INSURANCE.
AND THERE'S POINTED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
UNDER FUNDED.
A MUCH OF THE THE ISSUE I THINK
WE'RE SEEING IS THE FACT THAT
MANY OF THESE A POLICIES.
THEY ARE PERFECTLY REASONABLE IF
YOU. IF ONE HOUSE BURNS.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A WHOLE
COMMUNITY BURN AND THE THE COST
OF CONSTRUCTION GOES UP FIFTY
PERCENT. THAT NO LONGER WORKS
AND THAT'S A THAT'S A I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD OTHERS BUT THAT'S A.
VERY REAL CHALLENGE TO THEM.
THE.
THE OTHER.
THAT WE'VE HEARD WITH REGARD TO
THE BEAT REBUILDING PROCESS AT.
THE POINT THEY ARE IN THEIR
JOURNEY IS IS FINDING A
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES SURVEYING
GEOTECHNICAL STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ARCHITECTS.
YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY WASN'T
READY THAT.
FOUR FIFTY THREE HUNDRED HOUSES
TO GO AND FOR THE SERVICES.
DOT SO THAT'S THAT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE TO BUT THEIR THEY'RE
WORKING THROUGH THEIR WAY
THROUGH THOSE AND JUST WANTED TO
PASS ON THOSE.
A WITH REGARD TO THE CINEMA
COUNTY WATER AGENCY WE HAVE BEEN.
WORKING WITH MANY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES ON. ON ENCOURAGING
AND FINDING WAYS TO ALLOW THEM
TO REBUILD. BETTER THAN THEY
WERE BEFORE.
SO IN ONE AREAS AND ACTUALLY GO
THROUGHOUT ALL THE AREAS WERE
ENCOURAGING.
SYSTEMS THAT WILL INCREASE
FLOOD RESILIENCY LA DROUGHT
RESILIENCY.
AND AND AND FIRE RESILIENCY AS
WELL ENERGY.
LESS ENERGY SO WE'VE GOT WE'VE
TOWARD DEVELOPING LANDSCAPE
PLANS FOR DROUGHT TOLERANT
LANDSCAPES ROLE THE AREAS THAT
HAVE TO BE REBUILT. BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT ALSO GRADING
PLANS FOR STORM WATER CAPTURE SO
THAT HOUSE WATER RUNS OFF OF
THESE PROPERTIES THEY DON'T JUST
RUN OFF INTO THE STREET AND.
INTO A FLOOD CONTROL CHANNEL
THEY STAY ON THE PROPERTY AND
THEY INFILTRATE RECHARGE THE
GROUNDWATER TRYING TO RECONNECT.
THE THE THE WATERSHED.
THAT THAT'S BEEN DISCONNECTED IN
THE PAST.
ONE OF THE MORE.
SOMEWHAT INNOVATIVE AREAS WE'VE
WORKED ON THIS ONE COMMUNITY
THAT IS REALLY A IT'S AN URBAN
FISTS.
COMMUNITY BUT THEY'RE ALL ON
SEPT EX.
AND MANY OF THEM WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO CONNECT.
AND I'M NOT.
TOM.
I'M NOT JUST SAYING THIS BECAUSE
THESE ARE CHAIR BUT A BUT. I
REALLY DON'T AND YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT JAMES HAS BEEN ONE THAT IS
REALLY ENCOURAGED US TO BE BOLD
TO THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX AND HOW
WE COULD. HELP COMMUNITIES
REBUILD AND SO.
WE'VE WE FOUND A WAY TO.
WHAT THAT THAT THE WATER AGENCY
WE'VE HAD SOME FUNDING TO WHERE
WE CAN ACTUALLY DISH? INSTALLED
A NEW SEWER SYSTEM IN ONE OF
THESE AND ONE OF THE COMMUNITIES.
THAT NEEDS IT AND DEVELOPED A
FINANCING PROGRAM THAT BY WHICH.
ESSENTIALLY THE PROPER MANNERS.
JOHN THAT. AND THEN AFTERTEN
YEARS THEY WOULD START UP BUT A
TWENTY YEAR LOW INTEREST LOAN
THE IDEA BEING THAT. A LOT OF
WITH EVERYTHING ALL DIESE FIRE
SURVIVORS ARE DEALING WITH. WE
WANTED THAT KIND OF LET THAT
WAVE OF REBUILDING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES WITH
THAT PASS.
SO THEY CAN GET THE SYSTEMS AND
AND THEN TEN YEARS FROM NOW WHEN
THINGS HAVE SETTLED DOWN THEY
WOULD BE READY BUT.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE'RE
PROPOSING A MIDDLE BE GOING TO
OUR BOARD ON ON ON JUNE FIFTH
BUT.
THE.
.
BUT AGAIN WORK WERE REALLY
WORKING TO FIND WAYS TO REBUILD
BETTER THAN WE WERE BEFORE. WE
SEE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE OUR
OUR COMMUNITIES MUCH MORE
RESILIENT AND ALL FICKLE JUST
FALL ALRIGHT THERE'D BE GLAD TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
LATER.
TAKE VERY MUCH MISTER THOMPSON
SURPRISED OR.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S A
PLEASURE.
WHEN HE WAS JAMES GORHAM.
CINEMA COUNTY SUPERVISOR SUCH
OF OUR BOARD THIS YEAR BUT TO AT
THE SAME TIME I'VE.
WE'VE RECENTLY CREATED TO SEE
SACCADE FORTY STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES A RESILIENT COUNTIES
ADVISORY BOARD. WHICH HAS
MEMBERS FROM.
ON BOTH THE YEAH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE JUST OUTSIDE
AND ALSO THE COUNTY.
EXCUSE ME ELECTED OFFICIAL SIDE
THROUGHOUT THE Y. GEOGRAPHY OF.
OF CALIFORNIA IN SO I'M HERE
INCOME OF TWO DIFFERENT AREAS
ONE IS TO COME TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE ON WHERE ROUTE WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM. THE TWO WHAT IS
THE THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO SET UP WITH COUNTIES AROUND
THE STATE TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH YOU AND YOUR WORK.
AND I MEAN THAT VERY DIRECTLY
BECAUSE AS YOU ALL KNOW MANY OF
YOU COMING FROM STATE TO STATE
GOVERNMENT OR OTHER DIFFERENT
AREAS ARE HAVING CLOSE
CONNECTIONS TO THEIR. VOWS.
AS YOUR DIRECTOR OF OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES KILLER DUDE
SHE LIKES TO SAY AS YOU KNOW ALL
ALL DISASTER START LOCAL IN AND
LOCAL.
HOWEVER.
WHAT'S IN THE MIDDLE RIGHT I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT'S IN THE MIDDLE
YOU GUYS HAVE STEPPED UP IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A STEPPED UP.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE FELT THE LOVE
IN TERMS OF NOT LEAVING US
ASTRAY I MEAN THE AMOUNT OF.
IF IF I LOOK AT WHAT YOU ALL OF
HANDED OUT.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF NATURAL
DISASTER RESPONSE LITIGATION.
LITIGATION I'M GOT LOST ON THAT
TO PASS A SLAVE AND AT. THAT
YEAH THERE TO LEGISLATION WORK
WERE IN THIS PLACE WHERE YOU ALL
ARE SPONSORING SUFFERS WITH
RESPECT TO INSURANCE. ARE TRYING
TO FIX ISSUES THAT HAVE COME UP
REGARDING.
YOU KNOW PRICE GOUGING OF
UNKNOWN UNKNOWN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD ON THAT YOU KNOW AND THEN
WE LOOK AT THE BUDGET AND THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS IS THAT.
IF WE ARE LEFT ON OUR OWN UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES EVEN WITH
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
RESERVES IN OUR AREAS. WE ARE
DEALING WITH CATACLYSMIC KIND OF
SITUATION OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE GENERAL DAY TO DAY
SERVICES IF WE CAN'T.
BUT THE BIG FOCUS FOR ME HAS TO
BE THE NEW NORMAL AND ALL OF YOU
RIGHT. IS THAT HERE WE ARE IN A
SITUATION WHERE IF YOU LOOK
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES. IS
AT EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
OUT OF THREE THOUSAND AND SIXTY
NINE COUNTIES WERE UNDER MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATION THAT'S MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
IF YOU LOOK OF ABOUT FIVE YEARS
AGO WITH THE DROUGHT THAT'S MORE
THAN FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
COUNTIES THE ENTIRE UNITED
STATES HUNDRED MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATION. SO THESE ARE NOT
DISASTROUS ANYMORE RIGHT THE OUR
WHAT WE OPERATE UNDER AND IF YOU
LOOK AT YOU AND WHEN I TALKED
WITH YOUR EMERGENCY MANAGER DOWN
THERE IN YOUR AREA HE'S TALKING
ABOUT. SIX DISASTER DECLARATIONS
IN THREE YEARS FOR TALK ABOUT
NAPA SAME NUMBERS.
WERE AT SIX IN THREE AND A HALF
YEARS A WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH
IS THIS IS BECOME A PART OF OUR
NORMAL OPERATING BUSINESS. AND
SO PART OF YOUR NORMAL BUDGETING
IS WAITING FOR FEMA TO PAY YOU
BACK ON SAYING SO YOU'RE ALSO
WAITING ON ON DIFFERENT NUMBERS
COMING IN. YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING
AT ASSESSMENTS THEN ALL SUDDEN
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH LIKE
GRANTS LIKE HAUSER MITIGATION
GRANT PROGRAM APPLICATIONS THAT
COME UP. WHICH SEEM LIKE A LOT
OF MONEY BUT YOU GOTTA PUT A
QUARTER OF THE MONEY ON THE
TABLE. I MEAN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A MAJOR FULL COURT
DIFFERENCE
AND EVERYBODY WHO IS HIRED FOR
WHAT I WOULD CALL. COUNTY OR
CITY OR CITY OPERATIONS WERE
REALLY HIRED FOR DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS THEY WERE NOT HIRED
IN ME INCLUDED BEING ELECTED TO
BANISH THE NEW NORMAL.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE REALLY ASK
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP RIGHT IT'S
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE OUR FIRST
MEETING OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
RESILIENT COUNTIES ADVISORY
BOARD. OUT OUR LEDGE CONFERENCE
THIS WEEK. CAN OUR GOAL IS TO
FOLLOW UP ON WHATEVER THINGS
THAT YOU NEED WHETHER IT'S INPUT
FROM US OR WHETHER IT'S AS A
DELIVERY MECHANISM.
IN BUILDING OUR HOUSE OR
MITIGATION PLANS.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY MORE RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED. IN ONE OF THE WAYS
YOU CAN THINK ABOUT THIS IS
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT ALONE.
SO NO MY COUNTY RIGHT INCLUDING
CITY OF SANTA ROSA AND US.
NINE HUNDRED TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND DEBRIS REMOVAL MONEY SPENT.
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY WE
WOULD HAVE HAD TO SPEND TO
REALLY FOCUS ON UPSTREAM
MANAGEMENT OF OUR FORESTS.
AND GETTING INTO THE WORLD WHERE
WE DIDN'T STAVE OFF THAT NATURAL
CYCLE WITH FIRES AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO MANAGE TO
BE ABLE TO BE SMARTER AND
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS REALLY A CALLING I FEEL
FOR MANY OF US RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WE DEAL WITH PERSONAL PROBLEMS
EACH AND EVERY DAY. AND THEN WE
GET SMACKED IN THE FACE BY A
WILDFIRE.
LAKE COUNTY THREE YEARS IN A ROW
FIVE FIRES RIGHT SO I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO ACT EVEN AS WE
REBUILD IS HOW WHO YOU SIT HERE
AND EXPECT THE INEVITABLE TO
COME.
AND GET ARE PEOPLE READY.
SO.
DEBRIS REMOVAL NINETY NINE
PERCENT DONE.
THE PUBLIC PROGRAM O. WORKS VERY
WELL FOR US FOR US IT WAS
ARDUOUS THOUGH FOR PEOPLE WHOSE
THE FIRST CHOICE THEY HAD TO
MAKE. POST FIRES RIGHT AND THEN
IT WAS LIKE OH DO I GO THEME ARE
PRIVATE WHERE THE GOVERNMENT.
SECONDLY PEOPLE ARE DRASTICALLY
UNDER INSURED IF I COULD GIVE
ONE ONE STICK TO THIS IT WOULD
BE.
AS MUCH AS YOU ALL DEAL WITH THE
SPECIFICITY OF HOW MUCH PEOPLE
SHOULD BE INSURED BY OTHER
THINGS. JUST FOCUS ON THE FACT
THAT THERE'S NO COMMON PARLANCE.
IN THESE POLICIES
THERE'S NO STANDARDIZATION OF
EVEN HOW THEY USE WORDS
SO THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW IT
EVEN THE SAME PEOPLE WITH STATE
FARMER FARMERS OR WHATEVER OUR
TRYING TO BECOME EXPERTS ON
INSURANCE LAW. AND WHAT IT MEANS
AND HOW THEY DEAL WITH EVEN TO
THE HIGHER THIRD PARTY ADJUSTER
TO BE AN INTERFACE AND GIVEN TEN
PERCENT SO THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
SPEND THIRTY HOURS A WEEK DOING
THIS.
YOU NO.
WITH RESPECT TO REBUILD.
A LET THE DEVICE MAYOR TALK
ABOUT THIS BUT IN COFFEE PARKING
AREA THAT WE HAVE JOINT
JURISDICTION BUT YOUR LAND USE
AND IT'S IN THE CITY.
MORE THAN SIXTY HOUSES RISING
UP IT'S PRETTY INSPIRING.
BUT THERE'S A LOTTA LOTS THAT
ARE SPECULATIVE IN ON THE MARKET
OVER ON OUR SIDE ON THE COUNTY.
LARKFIELD WIKI UP AREAS COMING
ALONG ABOUT THE SAME ROUTE BUT.
BUT THE HILLS ARE SLOWER RIGHT
TO HILLS ARE SLOWER COST GOING
UP INTO THOSE AREAS. ALERT
MORNINGS WE'RE GONNA GO OUT WITH
A.
BASICALLY AT WE HAVE TO NOTIFY
THE.
THE FCC.
THER FORTY FIVE DAYS BEFORE WE
DO A COUNTY WIDE NOTICE WE'RE
GONNA WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS
WERE REQUESTING TO BE ABLE TO DO
ONE. IN EARLY SEPTEMBER AND
WE'RE AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
JUNE TWENTY JUNE ELEVENTH BOARD
MEETING TO PUT MORE MONEY INTO.
BASICALLY THAT THE TECH.
BECAUSE
IT IS BUYING LIKE SOFTWARE
PROGRAMS.
IF YOU BUY SO COOLER DOES IT
WORK BETTER THE NEXT HOLE DOES
NOT WORK LIKE THIS. BUT FOR YOU
ALL YOU TALKED ABOUT IT.
COMMON PARLANCE INVER* AND
HOW YOU ALERT IS IMPORTANT.
WE HAD SOMEBODY ON A RESILIENT
COUNTIES TASK FORCE FROM LA
COUNTY SAID YOU THINK IT'S HARD.
WE HAVE IN OUR COUNTY EIGHTY
CITIES IN OVER A HUNDRED SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
SO HOW DO WE ALERT PEOPLE WITH
ALL THESE AUTHORITIES TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT.
FINAL THING I IS IS FEMALE WE
ARE YOU KNOW THERE'S A BIG AREA
OF. OF THE BEST ACRONYM IN THE
WORLD HUD CBG DR.
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE DEVELOP BLOCK GRANTS
DISASTER RECOVERY DOLLARS
BUT TO LEARN TWELVE MILLION TAG
FOR CALIFORNIA FOR WORKING WITH
YOUR FOLKS LIKE BEEN METCALF AND
OTHERS. TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THAT SANTA ROSA IN
CINEMA COUNTY AS ENTITLEMENT
COMMUNITIES WHICH WE MEANS WE
USUALLY MANAGE OUR OWN CBG MONEY.
WANT TO SET THAT UP AS THE TO
GET ON THE GROUND AND AND PASS
THROUGHS BUT WE ARE ALSO HAVING
TO HIRE DISASTER CONSULTANTS TO
HELP US DO THAT.
BECAUSE AS YOU ALL OR IS HEARD
THEY WOULD SAY WELL WHY ARE YOU
TRYING TO GIVE GIVE ME TO GIVE
YOU A HUNDRED MILLION. IF YOU
NORMALLY ONLY MANAGED TO YOU GOT
TO SHOW US THAT YOU CAN MANAGE A
HUNDRED.
SO THAT'S WHERE YOU GET INTO
THIS WORLD OF CONSULTANTS AND
OTHERS.
ALERT MORNINGS I WAS ON A PANEL
WITH DOS WILLIAMS RECENTLY. YOU
KNOW WE'VE GOTTEN CRITICIZED FOR
NOT DOING ENOUGH WARNINGS AND I
WOULD SAY WE NEED TO DO BETTER
WE HAVE TO OWN THAT. ON THE
OTHER SIDE YOU ALL HAD I THINK
FROM WHAT HE SAID FIFTEEN
PERCENT COMPLIANCE TO A
MANDATORY EVACUATION.
UP. ON THE MUD SLIDES.
FIFTEEN PERCENT COMPLIANCE
SO THIS IS ABOUT REDUNDANCY OF
SYSTEMS IS THE ONLY TIME I'VE
HEARD THE WORD REDUNDANCY USED
IN A POSITIVE WAY. RIGHT IS LIKE
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING YOU KNOW
COPE CERTEON MISS CITIZENS
ORGANIZING TO PREPARE FOR
EMERGENCIES.
COMMUNITY EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAMS LIKE IN MARIN THAT ARE
VERY PRODUCTIVE. THE REASON A
LOT OF THESE HAVEN'T DEVELOPED
INTO REALLY GOOD NETWORKS IS
BECAUSE.
OF THE FEAR OF LIABILITY LIKE.
WE CAN'T POSSIBLY TRAIN PEOPLE
TO BE PREPARED FOR EMERGENCIES
COUSIN AT THE BEGINNING A
CERTIFICATE WE CAN GET SUED IF
THEY DON'T RESPOND IN THE RIGHT
WAY.
THAT'S THE STUFF THAT THAT
UNITES I'D SAY AND AND REALLY IF
YOU LOOK AT THESE CERTAIN COPE
TEAMS AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO I'VE ABOUT A. A NETWORK OF
ABOUT TEN THAT WERE STARTING AND
WERE ALREADY ON GOING IN NORTH
COUNTY.
THEY'RE SITTING THERE JUST TO
INCLUDE ALL FASHION COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING.
THERE'S LIKE A LOW. I MISS OUT
YEAR CURRY YOU OF AN ELDERLY MOM
ON YOUR PROPERTY YOU KNOW MISLI
MON YOU HAVE A WATER.
TENDER ON YOUR PROPERTY HOW DO
WE IF THE GRID DROPS LIKE IN OUR
CASE WERE SEVENTY FOUR CELL
TOWERS WENT DOWN.
FIRST NIGHT.
AND IF YOU DON'T EVEN EVEN IF WE
HAVE A SYSTEM FOR ALERTING COULD
YOU CALL.
RIGHT
SO THE TRENDS ARE OUT THERE AND
I JUST WANNA REALLY THANK YOU
ALL FROM THE FROM THE ASPECT OF.
C. SACK OUR GOAL IS TO REALLY IS
TO REALLY BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
YOU IN YOUR COMMITTEE AND THE
OTHERS TO SAY. IS THAT FORCE
MANAGEMENT THAT WE WANT TO THAT
WE CAN BE A PART OF DO WE NEED
IMPLEMENTED INTO OUR GENERAL
PLAN.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS IT THAT WE NEED
TO DO SO THAT WE CAN MAKE IT NOT
ABOUT SO NO MY COUNTY HAVING NOT
LEARNED ITS LESSON FROM SANTA
BARBARA SAN DIEGO OAKLAND.
AND NOW WE GO THROUGH IT AND
EVERYONE ELSE IS DOING THE SAME
THING.
SO REALLY HOPE THAT YOU GUYS CAN
HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN
HELP YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUPERVISOR
MISS MINNESOTA.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A QUICK PARA POINT I'M
GONNA GO TO JUST BECAUSE I THINK
VISUALS A HELP. SO THANK YOU
AGAIN OF FOR INVITING US HERE
TODAY AYE MONNING USE ON OF THE
COUNTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
SANTA BARBARA. AND I THE
SUPERVISOR ARTICULATED
EVERYTHING EXCEPTIONALLY WELL MY.
COMMENTS ARE BASICALLY
REFLECTION OF THAT. ALSO WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
BECAUSE I HAVE TO LET EVERYONE
KNOW DURING THE DISASTER SHE WAS
IN THE OAK EEOC WITH US ALMOST
EVERY YEAR ON THE PHONE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
DEBRIS FLOWS BECAUSE WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THOSE ARE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS IT'S
SOMETHING WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
SOME FLOOD IT'S NOT A MUD SLIDE.
IT'S NOT IN OUR VERNACULAR. AND
SO JUST QUICKLY WANT TO JUST
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DEBRIS FLOW BECAUSE THE DEBRIS
FLOW AS A RESULT OF THE FIRE AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT COUNTY OTHER
PLACES YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
MUDSLIDES AND DEBRIS FLOWS AND I
WANT TO. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE IT REALLY HAS A
HUGE IMPACT ON HOW WE'RE
RECOVERING.
SO OUR DEBRIS FLOW HAPPENED ON
JANUARY NINTH AND WE'VE BEEN
CALLING IT A GENUINE NIGHT
DEBRIS FLOW WE HAD OVER FIVE
HUNDRED STRUCTURES DESTROYED AND
DAMAGE WAS DONE OVER TWO HUNDRED
RED TAG. THEIR TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES WERE LOST ARE
STILL MISSING.
WHEN I ONE WHICH IS OUR
LIFEBLOOD CONNECTED TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD WAS CLOSED FOR
ALMOST TWO WEEKS WE'VE HAD
BRIDGES. DESTROYED PEOPLE STILL
CAN'T RIVERS AND WE HAD
UTILITIES OUT.
SO WHAT CAUSATIVE REFLOW FIRST
OF ALL IT HAD THREE THINGS FIRE.
STEEPNESS OF THE MOUNTAINS
BEHIND US AND AN INTENSE RAIN.
AND WHAT A DEBRIS FLOW WAS YOU
CAN SEE BY LOOKING AT THESE
PICTURES OOPS.
IS THAT IT WAS A WHOLE TORRENT
OF BOULDERS OF MUD.
TREES OF ROCKS AT JUST GUSHED
DOWN THE MOUNTAIN. VERY QUICKLY.
UP ABOVE THE FROM THE FEDERAL
LAND ABOVE US IT OVERTOPPED
ELEVEN OF OUR DEBRIS BASINS OF
THESE DEBRIS BASINS ABOUT THE
SIZE OF A FOOTBALL FIELDS.
CONTINUE TO FILL OUR STREAMS AND
CHANNELS EXPLODED INTO THE
NEIGHBOR NEIGHBORHOODS A CARRIED
WITH IT SUV'S HOUSES.
HUNDRED YEAR OLD TREES
BRIDGES.
UTILITY POLES THAT WERE BOBBING
UP AND DOWN IN THE DEBRIS FLOW.
AND SO.
IT CAME TOGETHER.
LIKE I SAID BECAUSE OF THE
STEEPNESS OF THE FORCE MOUNTAINS
THIS INTENSE RAIN AND THE HOT
THE HEAT OF THE FIRE.
SORT CHALLENGES THAT AS WE ARE
RECOVERING FROM THE DISASTER.
WE ARE STILL IN TO DISASTER
BECAUSE THE MOUNDS ABOVE US ARE
NOT GOING TO RE VEGETATE FOR
ANOTHER THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
AND THE SCIENTISTS HAVE TOLD US
WE ARE STILL AT RISK.
SO I'M LIKE A FIRE WHERE THERE'S
A THREAT WE RECOVER IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY HAS HAD TONS OF
FIRES WERE STILL UNDER THREAT
WHILE WE ARE IN RECOVERY.
AND TEAMS OF SCIENTISTS HAVE
GOTTEN TOGETHER AND THANK YOU TO
THE STATE THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGIC SURVEY CAL FIRE THE U.
S. FOR SERVICE THE STATE
WATERSHED TASK FORCE THEY ALL
CAME TOGETHER AND HELPED US.
COLLABORATE TO PUT TOGETHER OUR
RISK AND OR DEBRIS FLOW MAPS
AFTER THE FIRE BECAUSE EVERYONE
YOU AFTER THIS FIRE WE ARE AT
RISK FOR SOME KIND OF. OTHER
DISASTER.
IT'S A RESPONSE WE DEVELOPED.
AFTER THE DISASTER SEVENTY TWO
OUR PROTOCOL TO ALERT RESIDENTS
WHEN IT RAINS TRIGGERED SUCH
THAT IT WOULD TRIGGER.
POTENTIAL OTHER DEBRIS FLOW AND
THIS PAST WINTER WE HAD TO
EVACUATE PEOPLE THREE TIMES
AFTER THE DEBRIS FLOW. BECAUSE
THE RAIN REACHED A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD AT TIMES IS TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT WE HAD TO EVACUATE AND
ACOSTA TWO HUNDRED TO FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH
TIME IN PUBLIC SAFETY COSTS.
IT WASN'T JUST THIS AREA OF
MODESTY TO ITS BEING AND ALL THE
AREAS OF THE FOOTHILLS SO MUCH
YOU KNOW CARPENTER IN
UNINCORPORATED AREAS.
OF THE COUNTY AGAIN A SCIENTIST
WE JUST HAVE A PRESENTATION TO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SAID
YOU'RE NOT OUT OF THE WOODS YET.
BECAUSE THEY HIT THE FIRE WAS SO
HOT THE VEGETATION IS GOING TO
TAKE.
THREE TO FIVE YEARS TO COME BACK
AND HELP PREVENT AM FOR THE
DEBRIS FLOWS.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT REBUILDING.
AND SOME OF OUR CHALLENGES SO WE
HAVE THE TYPICAL CHALLENGES AS
WE TALK ABOUT FROM FIRE AND THEN
A MISTER NYGAARD ALLEN
CONSTRUCTION TALK ABOUT MORE
ABOUT WHAT HE SEEN IN THE FIELD.
BUT ENSURE WE HAVE SEVERELY
DAMAGED AREAS WHERE THERE'S NO
LONGER THE SAME PARCEL LINES.
THE LOT LINES HAVE MOVED AND SO
THE SURVEY MONUMENTS OF
DISAPPEARED BACK REDUCE
ESTABLISHING NEW SURVEY
MONUMENTS IN SOME AREAS SO.
HOMES OR NEAR A CREEK.
OUR CHANNEL ARE NOW IN THE CREEK
CHANNEL.
AS CHRIS OF WIDENED AND DEEPENED.
ESTIMATES COMING OUT THIS SUMMER
WITH THE HUNDRED YEAR FLOOD MAPS
OF THAT WILL NO BETTER WHERE.
OUR RESIDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO.
PREBUILT.
I'M WE'VE ASSIGNED CASE MANAGERS
TO HOMEOWNERS WHERE YOU KNOW
THREE MONTHS BEHIND EVERYONE
ELSE MEANT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
LIKELY THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS HAVE A LOCAL CHAPTER
OF THE VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME FRY
PRIVATE FIRMS HAVE VOLUNTEERED
THEIR TIME BECAUSE OUR SING WITH
THE CHALLENGE. HOW DO YOU
REBUILD THESE KINDS OF AREAS SO
THEY'RE GIVING A RESIDENTS
ADVICE
LOOKING OUT THE TOPOGRAPHY IS
CHANGED IN FACT THERE WAS A
WORKSHOP THIS WEEKEND WITH THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
GROUP AND SOME OF OUR RESIDENTS?
AND AS WE'VE HEARD MANY
RESIDENTS ARE UNDER INSURED HER
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH INSURANCE I
ASKED WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE
OUT THERE THEY SAID IT'S A
PATCHWORK. NOT THE SAME
VOCABULARY PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHEN SOME INSURANCE
COVERAGE COSTS AND OTHERS DON'T.
SOME HAVE STARTED TO MILL
DEMOLITION OTHERS HAVE NOT SO IT
IS A WHOLE PATCHWORK OUT.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
PHOTOS WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
MUD AND DEBRIS ON MANY OF OUR
PROPERTIES SO I'M LIKE A FIRE.
WHERE THERE'S DEBRIS IN ASH AND
ATTACH IT IS MATERIAL THAT THE
STATE OR A WILL REMOVE THIS IS
MUD? AND IT'S REALLY THE TOPSOIL
FROM THE FORESTS A ABOVE US SO
IT'S NOT HAZARDOUS MATERIAL AND
AGAIN IT'S BEEN A VERY COSTLY
FOR PEOPLE TO REMOVE. WE'VE
ENCOURAGE RESIDENTS IN FACT TO
KEEP IT ON SITE UNTIL WE KNOW A
BIT MORE ABOUT REBUILDING
POSSIBILITIES BECAUSE THEY MAY
HAVE TO USE IT TO CHANGE THE
ELEVATION OF GRADING ON THEIR
PROPERTIES.
.
WE'VE INTRODUCED.
SON THIS RECENTLY IN WAS CALLED
ARE A COUPLE MONTHS AGO AND IT'S
AN EXCHANGE PROGRAM LIKE A
CRAIGSLIST FOR HOMEOWNERS CAN
POST THEIR SOIL AND ROCKS.
AND OTHER PEOPLE CAN SAY THEY
THEY WANNA AND THEY'LL COME AND
PICK IT UP SO LANDSCAPE
COMPANIES ARE MAKING USE OF THE
ROCKS FROM RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES. FARMERS AND WINERIES
ARE COMING TO IMPORT THE
SENTIMENT FOR THEIR USE FOR
THEIR PROPERTIES.
SOME OF THE REST OF THE DEBRIS
GOES HAVE GONE TO PRIVATE
LANDFILLS SOME TO OUR LANDFILL.
ANOTHER ISSUE I KNOW THAT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
HAVE BUT LANDFILLS.
WE'RE REACHING OUR CAPACITY IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE STATE
AGENCIES TO TALK ABOUT THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS AND
WILL CONTINUE DO THAT BECAUSE IF
WE HAVE ANOTHER DEBRIS FLOW. WE
ARE WORD VIRGEN EITHER PARK
PASADENA.
IN A LANDFILL.
SO I'M TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
REBUILDING THEIR.
SO THIS IS JUST A PICTURE OF ONE
OF THE. OTHER DEBRIS BASINS IN
THERE'S ELEVEN ANSWER BEFORE THE
THE.
DEBRIS FLOW THESE THIS WAS
CLEARED OUT THIS IS RIGHT AFTER
THE DEBRIEF AND YOU CAN SEE IT'S
COMPLETELY FILLED AND ACTUALLY
OVERTOPPED.
IT COSTS THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS WHO WERE MISSION TASK
DO THIS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO CLEAR UP DEBRIS.
IT'S SO JUST LIKE.
THAT ON CALIFORNIA COUNTIES WE
HAVE A A LOCAL SHARE OF THOSE
COSTS WILL BE ASKING THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR WAIVER NOW
THAT WE KNOW THAT DISCIPLINE OF
THE CALIFORNIA. COUNTIES GONE
AWAY FROM THEIR LOCAL MATCH.
WE HAD DAMAGES TO OUR DEBRIS
BASINS ROADS BRIDGES CULVERTS.
AND AND LIKE I SAID WE HAD SIX
BRIDGES THAT WERE DAMAGED ONLY
TO UNDER CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON SHORT
LONG TERM.
SOLUTIONS.
LIKE CAN WE BRACE THE HILL OTHER
ENGINEERING THINGS WE CAN DO TO
KEEP THE ROCKS UP THERE.
CAN EXPAND AND FORTIFY THE
DEBRIS BASINS CAN WE CREATE MORE
OPEN SPEAK SPACE NEAR THE CREEK
SO THEY COME BECOME NATURAL
DEBRIS BASINS ARE WIDEN THE
CULVERTS ARE STILL LOOKING AT
ALL THAT. WILL BE SUBMITTING
THINGS TO THE STATE BE MATH WERE
HOME HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAM.
.
LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT TO
BROUGH BASINS ARE BLIND SO MUCH
ABOUT THEM AND REALLY BECAUSE.
AM I HAVE TO HAND IT TO CAL FIRE
IN MY STAFF AND OH YES YOU JUST
SAID AS THE FIRE WAS STILL
BURNING THEY SAID WE NEED TO
CLEAR OUT THE DEBRIS BASINS.
BECAUSE IF IT RAINS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A PROBLEM.
AND THEY DID THAT MAY SAVE MANY
LIVES BECAUSE OF THAT.
WE TALK ABOUT FINANCIALLY WE.
.
WE A HAD A PROPERTY TAX IMPACT
LIKE THE OTHER COUNTIESAN
INVOLVED. BUT VERMONT ACETO SO
EVERYONE THINKS OF HONESTY DOES
THE RICH RICHER. OF IT'S A SMALL
AREA OF OUR COUNTY IT'S ONLY
POINT TWO PERCENT OF THE WHOLE
LAND AREA. BUT IT MAKES UP
SEVENTEEN PERCENT OF OUR
PROPERTY TAX BASE.
IT HAS SIXTY PERCENT OVER SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE TOT FOR COUNTY
GOVERNMENT.
SO ALL WALL SO WE HAD A DROP OF
ONE POINT THREE BILLION JUST FOR
THE SOLE AREA MONTESINOS IT'S
COMPLETELY IT'S AFFECTED OUR
GENERAL FUND REVENUE. IT'S
AFFECTED THEM THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AS WELL AGAIN AFFECTED
OUR TOT BECAUSE THOSE HOTELS ARE
STILL OUT OF COMMISSION.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE COUNT THE
GOVERNOR FOR INCLUSION LOS TAXES
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
THROUGH OUR LOCAL DELEGATION ON
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
THE CHALLENGE WE FACE IS THAT
OKAY WE HAVE THIS DEBRIS BASIN.
AS A RESULT THE TOP OF THIS
DEBRIS FLOW AS A RESULT OF THE
THOMAS FIRE SO WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
IF WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE IS FEMA
GONNA BE THERE AGAIN FOR US.
THIS CALLAWAY THAT'S GOING TO
BE THERE FOR US THEY'VE BEEN
GREAT PARTNERS BUT FOR US THIS
INVENT IS NOT CLOSED AS WE ARE
STILL IN AN OPEN EMERGENCY. AND
WE WILL BE SO OUR RESIDENTS ARE
COUNTIES LIVING WITH THIS THREAT
AND UNCERTAINTY UNTIL THE HILL
STREET DO RE VEGETATE.
.
WE DON'T LOT THOUGH AS FAR AS
RESILIENCY ART IT'S REALLY
AMAZING HOW PEOPLE HAVE A STEP
FORWARD. HOW THAT'S PART
VERNACULAR NOW?
AFTER FEMA'S DISASTER RECOVERY
CENTER CLOSED UP SHOP WE OPEN UP
OUR OWN AND MY SEAT OVER IN THE
HEART OF THE COMMERCIAL DISTRICT.
AT THE CENTER PEOPLE RECEIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT THEY SPEAK
TO CRISIS COUNSELORS. TALK ABOUT
GRANTS IN BOTH SPANISH AND
ENGLISH THEY GET DOCUMENTATION
FOR INSURANCE WE HAVE ALL OUR
NON PROFITS HOUSE THERE WERE
THIRTY FIVE NON PROFITS OF COME
TOGETHER. A WE DO NEWSLETTERS
AND.
COMMUNITY MEETINGS.
WE EVEN HAVE A NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY GROUP THAT STEPPED UP
CALLED THE PARTNERS FOR
RESOLVING COMMUNITIES A FUNDED
COUNTY SERVICES AND. OTHER ONE
BE A MODEL FOR PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS HAVE BEEN REALLY
HELPING OUT OF PROVIDING MONEY
FOR EXPERTISE THAT WE
NECESSARILY COULDN'T FUND.
AND THE WHOLE COMMUNITY COME
TOGETHER FOR CAMPAIGN. ANNA
BENEFIT CONCERTS ON A LOT OF
PEOPLE HEARD ABOUT THAT SO WE'RE
VERY FORTUNATE THERE'S EVEN
CYNICAL THE BUCKET FOR GRADE. A
BUNCH OF FOLKS HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO HELP PEOPLE A TAKE
THE DEBRIS IN THE DIRT OFF OF
THEIR PROPERTY.
SO IN CONCLUSION WE. ARE MAKING
PROGRESS ON RECOVERY IT'S SLOW A
WE'LL KNOW MORE ONCE WE GET OUR
NEW FEMA MAPS.
IN THERE ARE SOME ASKS THAT WE
HAVE.
AGENCIES AMOUNTS THAT ONE WE
NEED NEW LIGHT ARE MAPPING THE
LIGHTER MAPPING IS THE LATER
MAPPING THAT LOOKS BELOW THE
BURN AREA TO SEE HOW MUCH GROWTH
VEGETATIONS OCCURRING.
WE NEED THAT OR TO SEE REFINE
OUR ESTIMATES FOR HOW THEM WHEN
AND HOW WE HAD OF HAVE TO
EVACUATE PEOPLE. A IN THE NEXT A
WINTER WE DIDN'T IMPROVE THE
LEARNING SYSTEMS AS SUPERVISOR
GORD TALKED ABOUT I KNOW THAT
CAL O. YES HAS A WORK GROUP AND
I MY OFFICE MY STAFF IS ON THAT.
WE LOOK FOR DISSING PROGRESS
AMOUNT ON TECHNOLOGY AND
PROTOCOLS.
ACROSS A DIFFERENT SELF FORM
SELF OF PHONE PLATFORMS WE NEED
TAX RELIEF WOULD YOU TALKED
ABOUT WHEN WE RIVER LOCAL MATCH.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR US WE
JUST NEED THIS RECOGNITION THAT
THE INCIDENT IS NOT CLOSED AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE M.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WELL. BECAUSE IT'S MISFIRES
ORGANIC KEEP ON GIVING AS FAR AS
KNOWLEDGE RECOVERY BUT SOME OF
THE OTHER AND. THREAT TO THEY
POSE
AND AGAIN WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AND
SUPERVISOR GORD HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD ON CD BG. OF FOR.
HELPING LOOK AT DIFFERENT WAYS
INFLEXIBILITY AND REGULATORY
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE CAN USE SOME
OF THOSE FINDINGS. A LOOKING AT
HAZARD MITIGATION PROJECTS
AND WE'RE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR CONTAINING
ACTIVATIONS FOR THE STORM.
SO I'M HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS OF
THANKS AGAIN FOR HAVING ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MISATO
AND OUT WHERE WE HAD A HUGE
CRUSH FOR TIME THIS AFTERNOON
BECAUSE SESSION WHEN.
REALLY LATE AND WE THE COUPLE
WITNESSES ON THE SECOND PANEL
THAT HAVEN'T.
THAT HAVE A OTHER OBLIGATIONS
SO I WANT TO INVITE THEM OUT.
TO I'D COME ON OUT MISTER DE AS
AN INDUSTRY NIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
COME ON UP AS WELL.
BECAUSE I KNOW THEY HAVE
SOMEWHERE TO GO THEN WILL COME
BACK.
ON SOME LOCAL ISSUES.
BUT AS YOU'RE COMING UP ON
SURPRISE ACCORD MENTION THIS IN
AND MISS MINNESOTA YOU YOU HAD
ALSO MENTIONED.
THAT.
DID THE DIFFICULTY WITH THE
FEDERAL GRANTS AND AID.
DO YOU. EITHER HAVE THE
CAPABILITY IN AND THAT BE THE
STAFF.
KEYS TO.
NAVIGATE ALL OF THAT OR IS THAT
WITH THOSE DISASTER CONSULTANTS
BECOME FOR YOU.
FOR US TO BECOME THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO THE DISASTER CONCERN
THERE OUGHT THEIR THEIR
EXPENSIVE ENDEAVOR IN FACT WE
USE TO.
I THINK THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
IS USING.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN. VERY
EFFECTIVE ARE WE'RETOLD BUT
IT'S IT'S EXPENSIVE ENDEAVORS TO
WE'RE PAYING FOR THAT BUT YEAH
THERE'S THIS WHOLE DISASTER
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX THAT HARD
BECAUSE YOU NEED SO MUCH
EXPERTISE TO GET YOUR WAY
THROUGH THE FEDERAL PROCESS WHAT
WHAT IS THE COMPENSATION LIKE
HOW DO YOU. MEASURE COMPENSATION
IS IT HOW MUCH MONEY THEY'RE
BRINGING IN IS IT BY THE HOUR
HOW DO YOU FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY
FOR THAT.
WE ARE PAYING IT OUT OF OUR
GENERAL FUND BUT IF THE I GUESS
THE RISK IF YOU DON'T DO THAT
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET YOUR FULL
REIMBURSEMENT COSTS AND SO AND
IT COULD NOT BE NEXT YEAR TO BE
IN THREE YEARS WHEN. A I G. DOES
THERE ON IT ON SOMETHING THAT
EVEN THE EXISTING FEMALE RAP OR
CALLAWAY SAID THAT SHOULD BE
FINE IN THREE YEARS AGO I JEAN
INSPECTOR COME CAN COME DOWN ASK
FOR HUGE REPAYMENT BACK SO.
THAT'S THE FEAR THAT WE HAVE SO
THIS IS LIKE A CONSULTANCY ON AN
HOURLY BASIS. YEAH IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF I COULD JUMP
IN AND HELP AS WELL.
ONE OF THE CHANGES THAT'S COME
OUT OF NATURAL DISASTERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY HAS NOW BEEN FEMA
ACTUALLY PAYING. IN THEIR
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR SOME OF THE
COST OF BRINGING IN A SPECIALIST
WHO IS ABLE TO DO THIS SO A LOT
OF THOSE FUNDS THAT YOU WILL SEE.
THAT'LL COME IN FROM EMA
ACTUALLY HAVE A PERCENTAGE OF
THEM THAT COME WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT MUNICIPALITIES
AND ARE GOING TO BE BRINGING IN
EXPERTS AYE IT'S NOT JUST ON
THAT FRONT WE IN THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA HAVE ACTUALLY BROUGHT
IN AN ENTIRE PERMIT. DEPARTMENT
TO TRY TO EXPEDITE THE REBUILD
THIS WELL MOVING OUR PLAN CHECK
FROM THREE MONTHS DOWN TO FIVE
DAYS A LOT OF THAT IS COVERED BY
BY FEMA AND THROUGH. BY OUR FEES
BUT TODD JUST TO CLARIFY.
SOME OF US IN UP MORE WAYS TO
GET YOU MORE MONEY ON A LOT OF
THOSE COSTS ARE REIMBURSED BY
FAMOUS TO APPLY FOR THOSE MONIES.
PERFECT FANTASTIC THANK YOU FOR
THE CLARIFICATION ON THAT THE
OTHER QUESTION THAT I HAD FOR.
SUPERVISOR GORE WAS ABOUT
DEBRIS REMOVAL BUT IT'S COMPLY
FOR THE THE OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
REPRESENTATIVES.
PEOPLE AND FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
IN THE HAVE FIGURED OUT PRETTY
QUICKLY.
WAS THERE A RIGHT CHOICE OR
KNOWS IT REALLY INDIVIDUAL FOR
FOR EACH PERSON THAT THEY TO
FIGURE IT OUT.
YOU KNOW IT'S A AS YOU UNTIL
THAT ONION.
YOU KNOW IT'S A FASCINATING
THING BECAUSE WHAT YOU REALIZE
IS FIRST OF ALL. IF LET'S SAY WE
DID NOT OPT IN TO THE GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM AND OFFER THAT WE HAD
FIVE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED HOMES
DOWN IN CINEMA COUNTY. IF WE HAD
NOT WHAT THAT MEANS IS YOU'RE
CONSCIOUS OPENING UP EVERYBODY
TO FIND CONTRACTORS.
TWO DO IT WHO ARE LICENSED AND
SPECIALIZED IN WHO COME IN HERE
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY AS MUCH AS
YOU CAN BLAME THE ARMY CORPS FOR
INEFFECTIVE.
YOU KNOW NOT BEING NIMBLE CAN
YOU IMAGINE THE LOGISTICS OF
HAVING THAT MANY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE FLYING AROUND EACH OTHER
WITH. WITH FOR THAT MUCH OF AN
EFFORT IT'S JUST IT'S IT'S IT'S
NOT CON OF FEASIBLE THE SECOND
THING IS IS THAT.
SO THE GOVERNMENT PROGRAM COVERS
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE INSURANCE
HAS FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL BUT
WHATEVER GOES ABOVE AND BEYOND
THAT. AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DON'T
HAVE WITH THE PRIVATE COMPANY.
NOW IF YOU LOOK AT LAKE COUNTY
THEY PAY THEN THEY HAVE AN
AVERAGE OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THEIR.
FOR THEIR RECOVERY EXCUSE ME
FOR THE DEBRIS REMOVAL PER LOT.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ONLY HAVE
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY THOUSAND
BUCKS TO REMOVE IT. BUT EMBEDDED
INTO THAT PEOPLE COULD
DEFINITELY POKE FINGERS AND SAY
WELL THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S A
GOVERNMENT COST.
I CAN GET IT FOR THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND YOU'RE LIKE
YOU'RE RIGHT BUT THAT'S BECAUSE
YOU'RE BRINGING IN SOMEBODY FOR
THIRTEEN BUCKS AN HOUR WHO'S NOT
WEARING. A PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND COMING IN AND DOING IT. IS
BY US GOING INTO THAT PROGRAM IN
MANAGING CONTRACTING IT DID
PROVIDE. YOU KNOW IT IS GOING TO
BE WAY MORE EXPENSIVE.
BUT YET YES HE'S QUESTIONS HERE
LIKE SHOULD WE REALLY BE
REBUILDING OUR COMMUNITY AND
HAVE A CLASS ACTION FOR.
.
FOR FOR LUNG CANCER ME SOMETHING
YOU KNOW MY FOR YOU KNOW TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW.
SO MY THING IS IS THAT IT WAS
CLARK KENT CLASSIC GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS IT WAS A BLUNT OBJECT.
AND WE NEED AT THAT AT THAT TIME.
AND DID YOU PAY MORE FOR IT YES
BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE THE
ALTERNATIVE
AT THIS POINT.
THE THING THAT WE NEED TO
TRANSFER TO OTHER COMMUNITIES IS
THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO PICK
THIS STUFF UP FROM VALID SOURCES.
EVERYBODY SPENT A LOT OF TIME
AND EFFORT MAY BECOME PREY TO
CONTRACTORS AND OTHER PEOPLE TO
RECREATE IT ALL THE TIME.
BECAUSE YOU ALWAYS PEOPLE SHOW
UP PAPER PARACHUTED IN THEIR
LIKE HEY WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
REPRESENT YOU TO FEMA. AND THEN
PAY US BACK SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
PAY US WITH THE FEMALE DOLLARS
THAT SOUNDS GREAT BUT YOU DON'T
KNOW IF YOU SHOULD GO WITH HIM.
WHOEVER WHATEVER.
SO MY ISSUE IS THAT.
IS THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
SHARING OF BEST PRACTICES AND I
THINK THAT'S.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH TO
SEE SACRAMENTO'S REALLY WANNA
FIGURE OUT IF YOU ALL? ONE PLUG
IS THAT YOU GUYS I THINK
TOMORROW IS WHEN ON THE
SIXTEENTH OR ON WEDNESDAY. IS
WHEN THE CAL O. YES STATE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN.
CLOSES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
RIGHT. ONE THING THAT MIGHT BE
INTERESTING FOR YOU ALL IS TO
HAVE A PRESENTATION ON WHAT THAT
IS
BECAUSE IT'S
SEEMED TO BE A TOP OF THE CLASS
AND ALLOWS IT TO GET MONEY
EARLIER ON. BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET ALL OUR COUNTIES TO RESPOND
TO THE STATE HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN. DRAFT
AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
BUT TO BE INTERESTING TO HAVE
YOUR TAKE ON THAT.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
WE WERE GONNA HAVE OUR NEXT
PANEL. OKAY.
AS A MEMBER OF A HOPI BRIEF AND.
QUESTION TO ACTUALLY.
THE THE FOLKS FROM SONOMA COUNTY.
BY IT YOU CAN'T HELP BUT NOTICE
THAT WHILE THE VAST MAJORITY YOU
KNOW THE LION'S SHARE OF HOMES
OF THE DEGREES BANG CLEAN THERE
STILL ARE. PLACES THAT HAVE NOT.
AND.
OBVIOUSLY THOSE ARE FOLKS WHO
OPTED FOR PRIVATE OPTION.
.
HOW YET WHAT'S THE PERCENTAGE OF
THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE IT
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE LIKE
THESE LITTLE ISLANDS OF ON?
I'M CLEAN UP DEBRIS.
AND WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO THE POINT
WHERE OUT OF OUT OF THREE
THOUSAND PLUS HOMES WE ONLY HAVE.
FIVE OUTSTANDING THAT ARE UNDER
THE ABATEMENT PROCESS BUT BUT IF
YOU LOOK BACK WE ACTUALLY HAD AN
EMPLOYEE WHO ALL SHE DID FOR THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FOUR MONTHS
WAS TRACKED DOWN PEOPLE.
WHO ARE POTENTIAL OBEY TEES
RIGHT AND CALL THEM UP AND THEN
EVEN GO ONLINE TO GO ON ANCESTRY
DOT COM TRYING FIND BECAUSE ALSO
AND SOMEBODY? MEANT I HAD SAY
THIS BUT SOMEBODY MAYBE THE
PARENTS PASSED AWAY THE HAVE
UNSETTLED THE THE PROPERTY AND
OUR GOAL IS TO GET COMPLIANCE SO
WE HAVE FIVE OUT OF THREE
THOUSAND THAT ARE STILL UNDER.
POTENTIAL ABATEMENT AND I DON'T
KNOW WHERE IT'S OUT WITH THE
CITY BUT I THINK THEY EVEN DONE
BETTER.
YEAH WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY MUCH
DONE WITH THAT I BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS ONE PRIVATE.
BUSINESS THAT STILL NEEDS TO DO
THEIR THEIR CLEARING A AS OF
LAST WEEK I HAVE TO CHECK AND
SEE IF THAT'S ACTUALLY BEEN DONE.
I THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN FOR THE
MOST PART FROM THE PUBLIC WHEN
IT CAME TO THAT THE PRIVATE
OFTEN IS.
A PIG EFFORT FROM THE CITY AND
FROM THE COUNTY TO GET PEOPLE
EITHER IN OR OUT MAKE A DECISION
THAT ALSO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH
PHONE CALLS FROM THE CAST
MEMBERS FROM THE SUPERVISORS.
REALLY ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO GET
THAT PROCESS MOVING BUT WE'VE
BEEN AT FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS HAS BEEN PRIMARILY ON THE
COMPLAINT SIDE. WHEN FOLKS HAD A
COMPLAINT ABOUT EITHER HOW MUCH
WAS TAKEN HOW MUCH DIRT WAS
TAKEN OR WHETHER AND NOT ENOUGH
WAS TAKEN AND REALLY HAVING
FEEDBACK COME THROUGH AND FIX
THOSE THOSE PROBLEMS. ACTUALLY
JUST SAID SHUT DOWN LAST WEEK
THE.
TOLL NUMBER TO CALL IF YOU HAD
AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN TRANSFERRED
OVER TO THE COUNTY NOW I BELIEVE
IS BACK UP AND RUNNING AGAIN
ABOUT WE HAVE NOT HAD TOO MANY
OF THOSE GOING FORWARD.
S. ONE FINAL QUICK QUICK
QUESTION AND THAT IS SAM.
SEEN WHAT HAPPENED IN ONE A
SEATO AND OBVIOUSLY THE
GEOGRAPHY IS DIFFERENT NOW THAN
IT IS IN SOME COUNTY.
I CAN'T HELP BUT WONDER THAT WE
WERE VERY FORTUNATE THIS YEAR
NUMBER ONE THE TIMING OF THE
FIRED TO THE INCREDIBLE WORK BY
PEOPLE HELPING TO.
SHORT THINGS UP SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE. BUT I CAN'T HELP
BUT WONDER IF NEXT YEAR. WITH
THE BURNED TREES WHERE THE ROOTS
ARE NOW ROTTED IF WE COULDN'T BE
IN A SITUATION WE COULD HAVE STE
COULDN'T COULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES AND SO. SO HOW ARE YOU
LOOKING AT MAINTAINING THOSE
THOSE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN.
THOUGH THE. THE THE BREAK IN
AND WORDS TO PREVENT THESE YOU
KNOW. SEMIS LANDSLIDES FROM OR
OF MITIGATING FOR POTENTIAL
LANDSLIDES BECAUSE THOSE
WADDELL'S AND ALL THOSE THINGS
THEY DEGRADE OVER TIME SO SO AND
AS WE GET INTO THE NEXT RAINY
SEASON WHICH. YOU KNOW IT'S MADE
ISN'T THAT FAR DOWN THE ROAD.
THE DEAD THE DEAD AND DYING
TREES THAT WE DON'T LOSE OUR
RATES.
AT THAT WE CAN GET SOME PRETTY
TORRENTIAL RAINS IN CINEMA
COUNTY. AS YOU OBVIOUSLY DID AND
AND.
AND I'M ON A SEATO SO WHERE DO
HOW YOU HOW YOU LOOK AT THAT.
YEAH I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S TOP OF MIND FOR
ALL OF US AS WE DO THIS NOT JUST
FOR THAT BUT ALSO DON'T FORGET
THAT IN OUR AREA THE BIGGEST
THREAT IS STILL GOING TO BE. A
BIG EARTHQUAKE SO HOW IS WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS DISASTER DO WE
CONTINUE TO PLAN FOR WHAT'S TO
COME THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
HYDRA SEED WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
ON THE HILLS. TO TRY TO PREVENT
THAT THEN THERE'S ALSO LOOKING
AT AREAS WHERE WE KNOW OUR WATER
SYSTEM IN PARTICULAR HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED WHERE THE PIPES OF
LITERALLY BURNED IN THE GROUND.
AT HAVE MELTED KNOWING THAT
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT
ON THOSE AREAS AS WELL AND TRIED
TO DO SOME MAPPING AROUND THAT.
MIKE SCREW ACTUALLY PUT TOGETHER
AN EMERGENT IT MONITORS.
THAT WE APPROVED IN THE OTHER
FUNDING BUDGET FOR.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND BUCKS TO
PUT INTO.
YEAH.
WE WE HAVE DUBBED TWELVE STE A
EXCUSE ME TWELVE RAIN GAUGES AND.
.
EXCUSE ME FOURTEEN RAIN GAUGES
TWELVE.
DREAM CAGES TO PROVIDE US WITH
EARLY WARNING SYSTEMS AND.
ONE OF THE.
IF THEY WERE WE WE DO OBVIOUSLY
CAN GET A LOT OF RAIN I THINK IT
THAT WHAT HAPPENED AND
MONOSYLLABIC ARE DESCRIBED AS A
RAIN BOMB.
IT WAS I THINK WAS A HALF INCH
OF RAIN IN THE HALF HOUR.
EVEN IMAGINE THAT I MEAN IT'S
LIKE BEING UNDER WATER I WOULD
THINK.
BUT.
THAT YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
DEFINITELY AREAS OF CONCERN ITEM
WE ARE. ARE TO PLUG A FEAST
MEANT THAT COULD HAPPEN BETTER
TOPOGRAPHY IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN. WHAT YOU HAVE THERE AND I
WOULD OF BEEN A WE CAN MAKE OUR
BANKERS CROSS WE ALSO HAD PP
CLASS WITH ABOUT? FOR IN A WE
WERE LUCKY WE HAD A WHICH CALL
THE IDEAL WATER YEAR THE IDEAL
WINTER WHERE WE WOULD GET THESE
AND NOT FROM A FLOOD CONTROL
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT WE WOULD GET THESE GREAT
LITTLE STORMS COME IN AND WET
THE GROUND STARTS STUFF GROWING
AND SO. THAT THEY ARE.
THERE OBVIOUSLY IS ALWAYS THAT
THREAT BY I TYPE I KNOW I'VE
BEEN OUT THE LOWER IN SEVERAL OF
OUR REGIONAL PARK OF SKYLER
REGIONAL PARK AND. THEY ARE
THEY'RE REALLY COMING BACK WELL
IT'S IT'S SURPRISING HOW MANY OF
THE.
HOW MUCH THE POTENTIATION YOU'D
THINK IS DEAD THAT ACTUALLY
ISN'T?
SO WILL WE KEEP OUR FINGERS
CROSSED AND HOPE WE DON'T GET A.
HALF.
HAVE YOU GUYS I'VE BEEN
AVAILABLE THOUGH IS THIS IS TWO
TO THREE YEARS AFTER THE AFTER
THE FIRES IS WHEN YOU HAVE TO
GET THE BIG FLOODS. OR THE
DEBRIS FLOWS EXCUSE ME WHATEVER
THEIR HAD.
BUT THE OTHER THING IS IS I I
DO WANT TO STRESS THAT PRIVATE
PROPERTY WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES IS BECAUSE.
UNLESS YOU'RE IN A COMMUNITY
LIKE.
LIKE UP WAY UP NORTH WITH WHERE
YOU HAVE A LOT OF BLM LAND OR%
FOR SERVICE LAND LIKE IN SOME OF
YOUR DISTRICTS.
YOU KNOW SOME MEMBER WOULD LIKE
IN A WAY UP NORTH YOU HAVE TO
DEAL PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS ALL
OVER THE PLACE AND THERE'S NO
MONEY TO GO IN AND DO THAT SO
WHAT WE DID WAS ACTUALLY USED.
SOME OF THE PHILANTHROPIC MONEY
LIKE FRANCE AND SOME CLEAN POWER
BUT MONEY ON THE TABLE WE ENDED
UP GIVEN. FIFTY GRAND EACH TO
ABOUT FOUR DIFFERENT.
WATERSHED GROUPS THAT JUST WENT
OUT AND THEY WERE LIKE WATERSHED
MARINES PUT UP WADDELL'S DOING
ALL THIS WORK. AND THAT IS A
HUGE GAP THAT NOTHING IS THERE
TO FILL. US DEPARTMENT
AGRICULTURE HOW SOME PROGRAMS
BUT IT IS IT. YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ACTUALLY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULDN'T BOTH YOU AND YOU KNOW
THAT CHAIR LEVINE AND YOU GUYS
WERE REALLY HELPFUL WITH US
TRYING TO. THINK THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF HIS THERE IS THAT
WATER BOND OR IT YOU KNOW IS
THERE ANYTHING OUT THERE TO HELP
PEOPLE AND PUT IN. APPLICATIONS
THROUGH OUR RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS TO DO
THIS BUT I MEAN YOU'RE ALWAYS
PLAYING CATCH UP.
AND THAT'S THE BIGGEST ISSUE
RIGHT I THINK THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU GUYS FOR DOING YOUR
WORK IS THAT.
ALWAYS REACTIVE AND EVERYBODY'S
LEARNING THEIR OWN LESSON RATHER
THAN LEARNING FROM OTHERS THAT'S
THE DANGER GOING AND FUTURE.
YEAH I DO WANT TO PUT IN A QUICK
PLUG TO IN OUR AREA THERE'S A
SOMETHING TO KEEP AN EYE ON
CALLED PEPPER WORD PEPPER WOULD
PRESERVE. AND THE PRESERVES
ESSENTIALLY A RESEARCH
INSTITUTION.
THAT LOOKS AT THE WAY THAT
NATURE REACTS TO CIRCUMSTANCES
HALF OF THE PRESERVE WAS I IN
THE FIRES OWN HALF OF IT WAS NOT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TAXI MAKE
RESEARCH COMPARISONS. BASED ON
WHAT THEY SEE AND INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH PARTS OF IT HAD GONE
THROUGH PRESCRIPTIVE BURNS AHEAD
OF TIME AT HALF OF IT HAVE GONE
THROUGH SOME CLEARING AHEAD OF
TIME. AND LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENCE IN HOW IT WAS
IMPACTED BY THE FIRE YOU HAVE
FIFTY STUDIES GOING RIGHT NOW ON
IT ALREADY WITH A BEFORE AND NOW
pSOME REALLY INTERESTING DATA FOR
THIS BODY TO LOOK AT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THANK AND I DO HOPE THIS BODY
AND LOOK AT THAT DATA.
IN THE FUTURE
AND.
I WANTED TRANSITION US TO
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHICH IS HOUSING AND HOMES
HOMES HOMES HOMES.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS
I THINK WOULD HAVE THE FOUR OF
YOU STATE BECAUSE YOU OFFICE AT
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE TO
SPECIFICALLY TALK ABOUT LABOR
AND BUILDING SPECIALIST.
ART THERE ARE STRATEGIES I
GUESS I IN OUR DISTRICTS. THE
REBUILDING PROCESS IS A LONG
PROCESS IT'S NOT HAPPENING AS
FAST AS OUR CONSTITUENTS WOULD
LIKE IT TO. AND SO I THINK I'M
GUESSING THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND REPRESENTATIVES HAVE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT MORE. AND IT JUST
BECAUSE OF YOUR TIME AND THEN WE
HAVE BUT WE DO HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE WE HAVE
SAYS THAT OF THE S. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDINGS TRADE.
ASSOCIATION.
WHO HAS WORKED ON A NUMBER OF
ISSUES RELATED TO HOUSING AND
THE LABOR FORCE ON WHICH SEEMS
WE MAY BE SHORT OF AT THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT AS WE THINK OF
ALL OF THE NEEDS BUT YOU WILL
TELL US WHAT WE? ARE WHAT IS
TRUE AND WHAT IS NOT A WHAT IS
JUST PERCEPTION.
BOOK AND SO SAYS IS GONNA SPEAK
AT A LITTLE BIT TO THAT BUT WE
ALSO HAVE SCOTT.
PLAN NYBORG GUY WHO IS THE
DISASTER RECOVERY OPERATIONS
MANAGER FOR ALLEN CONSTRUCTION.
A CONSTRUCTION COMPANY AD THAT
HAS BEEN AROUND IN SANTA BARBARA
FOR DECADES ON AND HAS DONE A
LOT OF WORK IN HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE FIRST RESPONSE OVER HOPING
THAT. AT THE BOTH OF YOU CAN ADD
TO THIS CONVERSATION FROM THE
LANDS OF THAT BUILDING. AND
LABOR.
PLEASE.
HARM THOUGHT THANK YOU SUMMON
MEMBERS OF FOR HAVING ME HERE IN
THE.
TAG OUT OF BOYS FROM LABOR.
.
AND TO ALL THE PANELISTS AS WELL
FOR THEIR INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATIONS A. I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE AND DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
THESE ISSUE THAT'S A STATE NOT
THE COMMUNITY FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
SINCE LAST YEAR WHEN.
WE WERE ON A.
WAS ACTUALLY ON THE DELEGATION
WITH A FEW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
WE LEARNED ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT
WERE HAPPENING BACK IN THE
DISTRICTS WITH THE FIRE AND HOW
IT IMPACTS A LOT OF MEMBERS THAT
LIVE IN AROUND THOSE COMMUNITIES.
YES IT'S
TO THINK GETS WORKING.
AND SO.
YOU KNOW WE HAD A LOT OF WE HAVE
A LOT OF MEMBERS TO LIVE IN THE
FIRE IMPACTED AREAS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR A LOT OF
THESE MEMBERS THEY NOT ONLY LOST
THEIR HOMES ARE TRYING TO FIND
OUT LIKE HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO MOVE AHEAD WITH
THEIR OWN CAREERS A LOT OF THEM
ARE PRINTS AS WE HAVE ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED APPRENTICES JUSTIN
SINAMA ALONE.
AND SO AS WE BECAME ENGAGED WITH
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS WITH
FEMA AND SOME OF THE CONTRACTING
PROCEDURES THAT THEY HAVE FOR
THE IMMEDIATE CLEAN UP. IT WAS.
RARELY AVAILABLE FOR A SECOND
IT'S NOTICEABLE.
THAT.
THEY WERE TRYING THEIR BASS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES THERE AND SO
THERE WAS A LOT OF DISASTERS
DURING THAT PARTICULAR TIME AND
THERE THERE ISN'T. AN INDUSTRY
AROUND DISASTER THERE ARE
CONTRACTORS THAT GO NATIONWIDE.
AS YOU HAVE KNOWN AND THEY THEY
BID OUT ON FEMALE PROJECTS AND
SO DURING THIS TIME YOU HAVE THE
DISASTERS IN THE EAST COAST. AND
PORTO RICO.
SO ALLOW THOSE CONTRACTORS HAD
LOCKED IN THOSE LONG TERM YOU
KNOW SORT OF CONTRACTS AND SO
WHEN FEMA CAME TO THE CALIFORNIA
THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT A
LOT OF THE. COMPANIES THAT WORK
HERE ALREADY WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THOSE FUNDS OVER THE
THOSE CONTRACTS.
AND SO THEY WERE IN THE FUNDS
THAT THEY WERE PUTTING OUT NOW
THEN YOU THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
RETRACTED THE WAY THAT THEY
ORIGINALLY PUT OUT THE FIRST
PROCUREMENT. AND THEN ISSUE THEM
OUT AT SERVICE CONTRACTS.
INTERNET SERVICE CONTRACTS THAT
CREATES A NEW DESIGNATION OF
CONTRACT AND AS WAS STATED
BEFORE IT LOWERED THE ROLE THE
WAGE RATES OF A LOT OF THESE
LABORERS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
BUILT BUILDING THOSE PROJECTS.
SO NOT ONLY. WAS IT NON BC FOR
US IN TERMS OF OF A UNION SCALE
WAGES WAS NOT COMPETITIVE FOR
THESE CONTRACTORS TO BOTTOM BID
ON THIS WORK. BUT IT WAS ALSO A
PROBLEM FOR THE YOUNG NONUNION
SECTOR OF CONTRACTORS IN THOSE
AREAS NOT KEEPING MONEY YOU WILL
KNOW THAT. WE OFTEN FIGHT WITH
THOSE SAME NONUNION CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATIONS HEARING COMMITTEES
SUCH AS THESE AND OFTEN FIGHTING
ABOUT. YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
STANDARDS WHETHER RETRAINING
APPRENTICESHIP OR ACTUAL WAGE
RATES.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE WE'RE
BOTH ON THE SAME SIDE BECAUSE
EVEN THE NONUNION CONTRACTORS
COULD NOT COMPETE.
WITH SOME OF THOSE.
RATES THAT WERE BEING PAID FROM
THESE NATIONAL CONTRACTOR
ORGANIZATION SO YOU WOULD FIND
THAT PEOPLE THAT DID NOT LIVE IN
AND AROUND THOSE COMMUNITIES
WILL COME IN.
AND ACTUALLY SEE
TO PERFORM THE WORK NOW. IN
DOING SO. IN A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE WOULD THAT WERE
MENTIONED.
BOB
FOR THEIR OWN SAFETY AND
PROTECTION.
DIDN'T HAVE THE TRAINING THEY
WERE HAZMAT READY OR CERTIFIED
FACT A LOT OF OUR UNIONS HAVE TO
RAMP UP IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
TRAIN OF THE HATS TAKE PLACE
WITHIN OUR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS LOOK IN THE AREA.
RETIREES CAME OUT YOU KNOW FROM
THE RETIREMENT APPRENTICES
JOURNEY PERSONS THEY ALL HAD TO
GO TO THE HAZMAT READING ITS
COURSE AND CATCH UP TO WHERE
THEY WERE BEFORE OUR PENSION
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY RAN. DAY AND
NIGHT OF FORTY HOUR OSHA
TRAINING TO GET PEOPLE READY SO
THEY CAN GO OUT AND DO THE WORK
AND GET PEOPLE BACK ON THEIR
FEET. BUT A LOT OF THESE OUT OF
STATE NONUNION INDIVIDUALS
DIDN'T HAVE THE PROTECTION THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE PROTECTIVE
CLOTHING OU DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
APPLY IT AND HOW TO USE IT
THEMSELVES.
THAT IS A PROBLEM FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THE PROBLEM FOR A
THINK ALLOW THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL BECAUSE IF THEY'RE NOT ONLY
TRAINED. SUCH A DEAL WITH
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS THEY OFTEN
WILL DISPOSE OF IT IN WAYS THAT
ARE NOT NECESSARILY HELPFUL TO
LOCAL COMMUNITY SO THAT YOU HAVE.
ADDED LONG TERM NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
BECAUSE GOD DEBRIS WAS NOT
HANDLED CORRECTLY EVEN. HOW YOU
COLLECTED THE BREED TO HOW YOU
ACTUALLY SHIP IT OUT OF THE
AFFECTED AREA? HAS TO BE DONE
CORRECTLY IN FACT SOME OF OUR
TRUCKS PARKED ON TARPS
SO THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY PULLING
SOME OF THAT TOXIC DEBRIS ARE IN
THEIR WHEELS AND THEN SPREADING
IT AROUND. SO THESE ARE A LOT OF
THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN THEY GO
INTO. OF THE IMMEDIATE ARE AT
WORK FOR RECOVERY
OUT OF THERE WE ARE ARMY OUR
UNIONS ARE PROUD OF OF THE OTHER
COMMUNITIES THEY OFTEN ARE THE
FIRST ONES THERE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
FIRES UP THE HAVE TESTIMONIALS
FROM OUR FRIENDS THE
FIREFIGHTERS WHO WERE OUT THERE
FIGHTING AND THEN HE OF
BULLDOZERS BASICALLY TRYING TO
CLEAR OUT. AHEAD SAID THEY COULD
HAVE SOME A LEAST A LITTLE
BETTER REPRIEVE A CLEARING OUT A
WHOLE BUNCH OF LIKE A FIRE
DEFENSE LINE IN A FIRE BREAK
LINE.
SO YOU NEED TO HAVE.
OF ACCESS TO A READILY SKILLED
IN AVAIL TRAINED WORK FORCE TO
HELP YOU NOT ONLY DURING THE
ACTUAL.
EMERGENCY ITSELF BOB ALSO IN
THE RECOVERY AND YOU MENTIONED
HOUSING RIGHT.
SO.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD THE CALL.
FOR WORKERS TO COME AND ADDRESS
THE WORKER SHORTAGE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE IS A
SORT OF A LINEMAN DISCONNECT
THERE'S GOING TO BE TONS OF WORK
IF A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
MENTIONED WITH REGARD TO
PERMITTING FUNDING. THE
INSURANCE ISSUES GET RESOLVED
BUT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH BUILDING
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
AND WHEN THE THAT ARE PAID OF SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER RATE THAN A LOT OF THE
JOURNEY PERSONS THEY'RE READY TO
GO OUT AND BE PUT TO WORK.
AND SO WE WANT TO PARTNER WITH
OUR CONTRACTOR ASSOCIATIONS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE THOSE
WORKERS ARE RE THERE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE SHIPPED THEN. THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE POWERS DANNY
AND IN ANY ON.
HOTEL OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THEY'RE READY TO BE PUT TO WORK
AND SO. WE'VE BEEN TALKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THERE ARE
THE CAN THESE CONVENING IS ALL
OF THESE GROUPS ARE BRING ALL
THESE RESOURCES TOGETHER TO
SHARE INFORMATION. EYES ONE THE
TO PUT ON THE RECORD THAT A LOT
OF OUR UNIONS WOULD BE ABLE TO
BRING IN THE WORKERS FROM OTHER
AREAS IF THOSE WORKERS AREN'T
THERE ALREADY. AND I THINK
THEY'RE ALSO WILLING TO TALK TO
CONTRACTORS ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
WAGE RATES THAT COULD BE
AVAILABLE SAID THESE COMMUNITIES
CAN BE BUILT UP AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. PARTICLE YEAH I WOULD
I WOULD ASK YOU LOOK AT THE USE
OF APPRENTICES.
BECAUSE THEY DO NEED.
THAT EXTRA LEVEL OF EXPERIENCE
AND A LOT OF THE SINGLE FILE ME
HOMES SO NECESSARILY NEED THE
HIGHER SKILL SETS WHEN YOU'RE
BUILDING A HOSPITAL OR POWER
PLANT OR SUCH THING. SAW WOULD
SAY THAT.
.
TAP INTO THE THE THE LOCAL
CONTRACTORS AND THEIR WORKERS
AND I THINK I YOU'LL BEABLE TO
FIND A LOT OF SKILLED WORKERS
READILY AVAILABLE.
I THINK AND ASSIGN NUMBER I CARE
CURRY'S SO ON THE ISSUE WE'VE
FOUND IS A MERCED RING TOLD
LACKEY MATERIALS MATERIALS COSTS
HAVE GONE SKY HIGH. IT'S GONE
FROM IN SANTA ROSA BELIEVE A
HOUSE WENT FROM AN A TO
INTERSCOPE DOLLARS A SQUARE FOOT
TO FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE.
AND.
SO LABOR IS AN ISSUE AND WE
TALKED IT'S IN THE AREA LAKE
COUNTY IS THE WORST BY FAR.
CAMPAIGNING WORKERS UP THERE
BECAUSE THEY COULD REALLY GET
THE BETTER WAGE DOWN IN SANTA
ROSA. SO IT'S STILL A LABOR
THING FOR US AND I DON'T. I'M
FRY GET FRUSTRATED JUNE TWENTY
HOW CAN WE GET MORE PEOPLE IN
HERE YOU'RE SHOWING ME WE HAVE
PLENTY OF WORKERS TO BUILD HOMES
RIGHT NOW. DR YEAH ABSOLUTELY I
THINK IF YOU DEVELOP BE A.
I MEAN THEY THEY TALKED ABOUT
AND IN THIS WORKING GROUP HOW TO
SIGN. UP PROJECTS OF SCALE RIGHT
IT'S IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT AN
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNER AND THEY'RE
OUT THERE TRYING TO FIND A
CONTRACTOR THEY'RE DEALING WITH
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE CUT
OFF ON THEIR OWN. THERE MIGHT BE
SOME DIFFICULTIES THERE FOR
TRYING TO TO GET.
THAT PROJECT UP AND RUNNING.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE PART
OF WAS LOOKING AT ENTIRE AREA.
AND BE ABLE TO SORT OF BLOCK IT
OUT THAT THERE BE A ONE
CONTRACTOR A CENTER CONTRACTORS
THAT ACTUALLY DO THE REBUILDING
ON THERE. AND THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT TYPE OF SCALE YOU MAY HAVE
MORE WORKERS THAT WILL BE OUT
TITLE BAILABLE TO THAT
CONTRACTOR ABOUT SPECIFIC
PROJECT. BECAUSE NOW IT'S NOT
JUST ONE SINGLE PALM AS A
MULTITUDE OF THE ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT CAME UP WAS IN
COFFEE PARK. WE HAD I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY HOMES GO. A DEVELOPER
HAD THOUGHT THAT HE WANTED TO
FACE COULD DO THE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE GOING TO TAKE IT OVER.
INNOCENTS BACKED UP.
NOT BECAUSE TO EXPENSIVE FOR HIM
TO GET EMPLOYEES FROM POINT A IN
THE BAY AREA. AND TO DRIVE UP TO.
CENTER ROSA IS NO HOUSING.
WE NOTE THE POPLAR THROW THINGS
OR ARE IN THE WAY.
AND THERE'S MANY FIVE RESIDENTS
OF LIVING UP THERE THAT ARE IN
THE HILLS THEIR ONE OFFS.
SO I MEAN THERE'S A LOT HERE IN
I JUST I I I I JUST LOOK FOR
MORE HELP ON THE LABOR SIDE IS
TO HIM YOU KNOW HELP OUT.
YOU KNOW I I UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE GENTLEMAN CAME FROM FROM THE
BAY AREA SAID. IN THIS IS A
PENCIL OUT WELL RIGHT. IN THE
MEANTIME I HAVE PEOPLE WITHOUT A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD. IT'S
UPSETTING TO ME TO THINK THAT
BUT HOW DO WE MOVE THIS ALONG.
I'M I THINK THE COUNTY HAS DONE
A PHENOMENAL JOB OF TRYING TO
MOVE PERMITTING ALONG IN THEIR
INSPECTIONS ALONG I THINK THAT
THEY HAVE. STEPPED UP SANTA ROSA
STEPPED UP TO COUNTY STEPPED UP
SO.
THIS ONE PIECE LIKE WE HOW WE
GET THERE.
AS WELL AS IT IS JUST THE
MATERIALS THEMSELVES REPEAL OF
CEMENT I CAN GET LUMBER RIGHT
NOW I CAN'T GET THIS YOU KNOW SO.
THERE'S A LOT TO THIS IS NOT
JUST I'M NOT FINGER POINTING AT
LABOR NECESSARY GOING TO SING.
THERE'S SO MUCH HERE AND WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT SO IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE SAME VOTE
SO.
UNTIL I THINK.
.
WENT WHEREVER THERE'S WORK
AVAILABLE ONCE BUT IT'S PRETTY
GOOD CONSTRUCTION RIGHT AND
THERE IS A A.
SIGURD ECONOMY RIGHT NOW FOR A
CONSTRUCTION WORKER.
AND THEN THAT THEIR WAGES
ACTUALLY BECOME MORE COMPETITIVE
I THINK THAT'S ALWAYS THE CASE.
ARMED WITH REGARDS TO LUMBER
MATERIALS AND AND ALL THAT BUT I
THINK THAT IT JUST.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A BUILDING
BOOM AND YOU LOOK IN AN AREA
THAT NEEDS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
MATERIALS ALL AT ONCE AND I
THINK THAT IN THAT CASE. THERE
IS SORT OF A MARKET TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AS WELL
THAT THING THAT'S WHERE
GOVERNMENT CAN STEP IN. AND
ASSIST A LOT OF THESE HOMEOWNERS
AND TRY TO HELP THEM GET OFF ON
THEIR FEET WITH GRANTS OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE. I THINK.
.
WE'VE HEARD EXAMPLES OF THAT AS
WELL WHERE A CONTRACTOR HAS
AHEAD JUST CAN'T FIND THE
WORKERS.
AND WHEN I HEAR THAT I
IMMEDIATELY CALL MY LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES WORK BUT UNIONS
AND SAY HEY THIS CONTRACTOR HAD
JUST SIGNAL THAT THEY CANNOT
FIND THE WORKERS. HAVE THEY
CALLED YOUR HALL.
HAVE THEY TALKED YOU HAD THEY
DID A SURVEY OF YOUR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS AND WHO'S ON THE BOOKS
AND IT WAS ON I'M IN THE
HALLWAYS WHEN FOR WORK. NONE OF
THAT HAS HAPPENED SO I THINK
THERE'S A DISCONNECT OR PERHAPS
A FEAR OF NOT REACHING OUT TO
THE BUILDING TRADES UNIONS
BECAUSE THEY WILL BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE A COST INCREASE.
THAT'S WHY I MENTIONED THE USE
OF APPRENTICES BECAUSE THAT
APPRENTICE WAGE RATE IS FORTY
PERCENT THAT OF A JOURNEY PERSON
WAGE RATE.
SO SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER WHEN
YOU'RE TURNING OFF A FIRST YEAR
APPRENTICE.
AND IF THOSE JOBS WERE TO BE
OPEN I THINK THE OPPRESSION
PAUL'S WOULD OPEN UP FOR MORE
NEW WORKERS TO ACTUALLY ACCESS
AND THAT'S WHAT I MEAN YOU KNOW
ONE REAL QUICK EXAMPLE.
A GENERAL'S UPON A HE'S A
PLUMBER HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
HE HAS A VAN FILLS UP WITH THE
TRAILER ON THE BACK GOES TO
LOW'S OR TO HOME DEPOT EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
FILLS IT UP IN SACRAMENTO AND
TAKES IT OVER TO.
.
TO SANTA ROSA TO WORK.
AND HE DOES NOT PICK UP ANY
OTHER SUPPLIES AND SANTA ROSA OR
ANYWHERE ELSE BECAUSE HIS
FREIGHT IF YOU HOOKS INTO HOME
DEPOT OR LOW WHEREVER IT MIGHT
BE.
HIS ILLNESS IS EMPLOYEES.
SO HE BRINGS HIS EMPLOYEES EVERY
SINGLE DAY BACK AND FORTH AND
ONLY PICKS UP HIS A HAS A PIPE
FITTINGS OR WHATEVER YOU HAVE TO
PICK UP. HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
TRUE STORY.
THE OKAY LET ME THAT HE DOESN'T
WORKERS AT HOME ANY THE LOSES
EMPLOYEES RIGHT. BECAUSE PEOPLE
AREN'T OUR SCALP EMPLOYEES OF
MAN OF RIGHT NOW SOME OF THESE
PLACES SO ANYWAY. JUST WANTED TO
LET THAT THAT THEY LET YOU GO ON.
SOME SORRY SCOTT MAYBE YOU CAN
ADD TO THIS THAT HOOKAH.
LIKE TO. THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR.
INVITING US TO BE HERE AND FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO THESE MATTERS.
.
BUT IT'S GOT NYBORG.
IT NORMALLY THE SUSTAINABILITY
MANAGER DOWN CONSTRUCTION BUT.
MOST RECENTLY DISASTER RECOVERY
OPERATIONS.
WHICH I HOPE IS A.
A TEMPORARY TITLE.
.
WE HAVE A THIRTY SIX YEAR
HISTORY IS GENERAL CONTRACTOR IN
SANTA BARBARA.
ON THE SEAT OF INSURER.
THE AREAS AFFECTED BY THE
THOMAS FIRE THE MUNCIE SO.
DEBRIS FLOW. AND.
HAVE MADE THE RECOVERY EFFORT.
FRONT AND CENTER.
AND.
FOR AS LONG AS IT TAKES TO HELP
REBUILD OUR COMMUNITY.
.
LIKE TO. SHOW YOU SOME PICTURES
FROM PROJECTS THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON AND TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH.
TICKETS DOWN.
A LEVEL OF GRANULARITY FOR YOU
AS WELL WORD NE.
YOU'RE DEALING WITH INDIVIDUAL
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS.
UNTIL CERTAINLY NONE OF THE.
THE PUBLIC WORK SCALE.
CHALLENGES THAT MY COLLEAGUES
ARE DEALING WITH.
.
IT HAS INVOLVED IN MONEY ZERO
THAT ARE PROJECTS.
SO NATURALLY DIVIDE THEMSELVES
INTO THREE PHASES OF THE FIRST
STEP IS THE EMERGENCY.
DEBRIS REMOVAL.
DEMOLITION OF STRUCTURES THAT.
.
HAVE HAVE BEEN.
DAM IS BEYOND SALVATION ALSO
DEMOLITION PARTIAL DEMOLITION OF
STRUCTURES THAT DOWN.
CAN BE SALVAGED.
.
THAT STEP IS SUBSTANTIALLY
COMPLETE ON MANY OF OUR PROJECTS
AT THE CERTAINLY OUR HOMES IN
THE AREA THAT.
.
THAT HAVE THIS YET AHEAD OF
THEM THE SECOND PHASE IS.
A PAUSE AND ON SITE OPERATIONS
WHILE WE HELP OUR CLIENTS TO
DEAL WITH.
.
INSURANCE SETTLEMENTS
AND.
OBTAINING RECONSTRUCTION
PERMITTING.
AND FINALLY.
WE GET TO THE RECONSTRUCTION.
ITSELF.
.
I SHARE WITH YOU SOME.
FIGURES ABOUT ALLEN
CONSTRUCTIONS.
SLICE OF THE RECOVERY EFFORT
MANSIO.
WE'RE DEALING WITH
APPROXIMATELY FORTY CLIENTS
ABOUT HALF OF THOSE.
HAVE WHAT WE CALL HEAVY CLEANUP
WORK.
OR HAVE HAD HEAVY CLEANUP WORK.
BY WHICH I MEAN DEALING WITH
THE LIKES OF WHICH YOU SEE IN
THE PICTURE.
.
THE.
IT INTENSE PORTION OF THAT
CLEANUP WORK IS BEHIND US.
WE SPENT A VERY INTENSE. ELEVEN
WEEKS
AND THAT EFFORT EMPLOYING
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIELD CREW
SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF
SPECIALIST TRADES.
DEDICATED ABOUT SEVEN OFFICE
STAFF FULL TIME TO SUPPORT AND
THAT TEAM ON THE FIELD. AND
DURING THAT TIME CLEARED ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED CUBIC YARDS
OF DEBRIS THAT AGAIN THIS IS
THIS IS PRIVATE MODE.
CHRIS SO THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES
AREN'T AREN'T.
TAKE ANY PART OF THE CLEARING
OF THIS DECREE. THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
DUMP TRUCKS.
.
ID CHIEF CHALLENGES DURING THAT.
DURING THAT PHASE OF COURSE
FIRST AND FOREMOST IT'S BEEN THE
SAFETY OF OUR CREWS ASSISTANCE
OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
CONSTRUCTION WORK THAT I'VE EVER
BEEN INVOLVED IN MY CAREER.
IN CONSTRUCTION.
SECONDARY TO THAT HAS BEEN THE
CHALLENGE OF ACCESS AMONG US IT
WAS ACTUALLY CLOSED AND RIGHTLY
SO.
TO CLEAN UP CREWS.
WHILE THE FIRST RESPONDER
EFFORT WAS UNDERWAY. UPON.
THE.
YOU THE OTHER EDGE OF THE SWORD
HOWEVER HAS BEEN THAT THESE
HOUSES SAT ENCASED IN MUD AND
DEBRIS FOR APPROXIMATELY A MONTH.
BEFORE WE COULD EVEN START TO
DIG THEM OUT.
AND SO THERE IS SOME
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING DAMAGE
DURING THAT TIME.
EVEN ONCE TOWN WAS OPENED UP TO
PRIVATE CLEAN UP CREWS.
ACCESS BEEN DIFFICULT ISSUE
ROAD CLOSURES THERE'S BRIDGES
THAT HAVE STILL NOT BEEN
RECONSTRUCTED.
AND EVEN WITHIN THE FOR
PROPERTY LINES.
WE'VE HAD SOME SIGNIFICANT
ACCESS CHALLENGES GETTING TO THE
BUILDINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
CONTRACTED TO.
TO WORK ON.
LOGISTICALLY LABOR AND EQUIPMENT
AVAILABILITY HAS BEEN A SERIOUS
CHALLENGE FOR US AS HAS THE
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE DUMP
SITES.
SO A DAILY CHALLENGE DURING
THOSE ELEVEN WEEKS OF HEAVY
CLEAN UP WAS.
.
FINDING DEBRIS SITES THAT WE
COULD AFFORD TO EXPORT TO.
OR THAT OUR CLIENTS COULD
AFFORD TO EXPORT TO.
DOT WAS SOME TECHNICAL
DEMOLITION CHALLENGE THE LIKES
OF WHICH. YOU SEE IN THE PICTURE.
THAT'S NOT THE PURVIEW
TYPICALLY.
OF A HOME BUILDER.
AND I PUT CASH FLOW ON THE LIST
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THIS WAS A
LIMITING FACTOR AND THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT WE WERE.
ULTIMATELY ABLE TO HELP SO.
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE CLEANUP
PHASE WE HAVE FRONTED A LOT MORE
THAN THREE QUARTERS OF A MILLION
DOLLARS. OF.
UNPAID RECEIVABLES THAT'S A
HEAVY BURDEN FOR A SMALL PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO BEAR.
AND THAT DID ULTIMATELY.
CURTAIL THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO HELP AND SO.
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE SPEED OF
THE CLEAN UP WORK VERSES THE
SPEED WITH WHICH.
INSURERS WERE ABLE TO PAY OUT.
ON THOSE COSTS.
.
WHO WAS WHO WAS IMPACTFUL IN
THAT WAY?
OUT FOR US.
THIS IS MY COLLEAGUE AND CROTCH
US STANDING IN FRONT OF A SMALL
MOUNTAIN OF MUD THAT WE'VE
STOCKPILED FOR.
EXPORT FROM THIS PROPERTY.
AND IN THIS GRAPHIC YOU CAN SEE.
THAT INDIVIDUAL PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS.
THAT WERE WORKING FOR A HAVE
HAD TO EXPORT AS MUCH AS A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DUMP TRUCKS.
OF MATERIAL FROM THEIR PROPERTY.
AGAIN THIS IS THIS IS CLEARING
THAT THEY ARE ENTIRELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR.
SUPPORTED ONLY BY.
ANY SETTLEMENT THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SECURE.
FROM THEIR INSURERS.
WHEN YOU FIGURE THAT PER CUBIC
YARD WE'RE LOOKING AT DISPOSAL
COSTS OF ANYWHERE FROM FORTY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND HIGHER.
DURING THE NOW YOU KNOW WILD
FLUCTUATIONS IN THE IN THE.
AND THE MARKET FOR DISPOSAL.
PLUS LABOR TO HANDLE THIS
MATERIAL YOU CAN SEE WHY DEBRIS
CLEARING HAS BEEN SUCH A HEAVY
EXPENSE FOR.
THESE HOMEOWNERS.
ONE THING I WILL APPLAUD
INSURERS FOR IS THE DECISION TO
COVER THESE COSTS.
.
OVER AND ABOVE WHAT IS
TRADITIONALLY THE DEBRIS.
REMOVAL THAT THE DIVERT
DISAPPROVAL COVERAGE AT LIMIT ON.
MOST HOMEOWNERS POLICIES
HOWEVER.
THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT IS THAT
THE AGGREGATE A LIMIT ON THE
POLICY REMAINS AND SO HE'S VERY
HIGH COSTS OF DEBRIS REMOVAL
WHICH HOMEOWNERS POLICIES
GENERALLY WEREN'T DESIGNED TO
DEAL WITH. ARE ERODING.
HOMEOWNERS.
RESOURCES FOR RECONSTRUCTION.
AS THE HEAVY CLEANUP HAS COME
TO A CLOSE.
AGAIN OPERATIONS ON SITE HAVE
COME TO SOMEONE OF A PAUSE WHILE
WE DEAL WITH TWO PRIMARY
CHALLENGES ONE IS.
HELPING OUR CLIENTS SECURE
INSURANCE SETTLEMENT THE OTHERS
HELPING THEM SECURE PERMITS
AFTER RECONSTRUCTION.
THERE'S BEEN.
LARGE DISPARITY INSURERS
WILLINGNESS OR FOR COMING THIS
IN AND HELPING US TO COVER. ALL
THESE LOSSES ARE NOTABLE FEW
HAVE BEEN VERY FORTHCOMING.
WAS SUPPORT FOR OUR POSITION
WITH REGARD TO SCOPE OF WORK.
THE COST THEREOF.
BUT MANY HAVE NOT.
.
JUST TALK ABOUT THE WAY THE
DEBRIS REMOVAL COSTS CAN A ROAD.
THE RECONSTRUCTION BUDGET.
.
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE KIND OF.
THINGS WHERE ALLEN CONSTRUCTION
IS FOUND ITSELF IN DISAGREEMENT
WITH INSURERS IS FOR EXAMPLE.
APPROPRIATE MEANS AND METHODS
FOR THE RESTORATION OF THE
PROPERTY.
AND.
GETTING COVERAGE FOR THINGS
LIKE PROJECT MANAGEMENT AND
GENERAL CONDITIONS WHICH ARE THE
VERY REAL AND NECESSARY.
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH LARGE
TECHNICAL RESTORATION PROJECTS
LIKE THIS.
JOURNAL CONDITIONS FOR THOSE
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE TERM A
BASICALLY THE LOGISTICAL COSTS.
.
GENERAL CONTRACTOR IN EXECUTING
ANY KIND OF A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT.
.
WE ALSO EXPERIENCED THAT
ADJUSTERS COST DATABASES ARE ARE
WILDLY OUT OF WHACK WITH.
WITH REAL ON THE GROUND
CONSTRUCTION COSTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST
EXPECT THIS IS A PROBLEM ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA.
ESPECIALLY FOR US AND THE
LENGTH OF THE WORK FLOW.
WITH SOME OF THE CARRIERS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH.
HAS REALLY. BEGUN TO BE A
BURDEN I FEEL TO.
TO THE HOMEOWNERS.
ELECTED TIP MY HAT FOR A MOMENT.
TO MY COLLEAGUES IN.
THE VARIOUS PUBLIC AGENCIES OF
THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT.
BUILDING APARTMENT FLOOD
CONTROL DEPARTMENT AND THE
COUNTY SANTA BARBARA HAVE.
I THINK REALLY THE LOTS GET
THEIR ARMS AROUND SOME NOVEL
PROBLEMS.
.
ANIMOSITY MIGHT FLORA CHALLENGE
FOR US BUT ONE THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY NEGOTIATE
THANKS FOR THEIR HELP HAS BEEN.
.
HAS HAS BEEN KEEPING ABREAST OF
THE OF THE DEVELOPMENTS THE
SOLUTIONS.
THE.
THE WORKFLOWS THAT HAVE EMERGED.
.
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE PRIMARY
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE.
WORKING WHO NOW WITH OUR WITH
OUR PUBLIC COUNTERPARTS IS.
.
THE REMAPPING OF MODESTY THOUGH
AND THE MONEY AND THE.
THOUGHT THINGS THERE AND.
AS.
AS WAS EARLIER STATED OF THE
HYDROLOGY OF THE REGION HAS BEEN
CHANGED BY THE DEBRIS FLOW. AND
SO THE FLOODPLAIN IS NO LONGER
RATE USED TO BE.
NOBODY'S QUITE SURE WHAT THE
BASE FLOOD ELEVATION AS BUT THAT.
THAT MAP INFORMATION IS
FORTHCOMING THE NET EFFECT OF
THAT IS THAT SOME OF OUR CLIENTS
MAY BE.
AT LEAST AT RISK.
TO COMPLY WITH THE RULE TO
RAISE THEIR HOMES UP OUT OF THE
FLOOD PLAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THE HOMES
AREN'T GENERALLY A TOTAL LOSS
THE DIFFERENCE IN COST BETWEEN.
RAISING THE HOME WHICH CAN
WHICH CAN BE.
EITHER NEARLY ORG REALLY
COMPLETELY A REBUILD OF THE HOME.
VERSUS JUST BUILDING BACK IN
KIND ARE REALLY SIGNIFICANT AND
THERE IS SUCH INTENSE COST
PRESSURE ON THESE PROJECTS THAT
MANY OF OUR CLIENTS ARE
DIRECTING US.
TO HELP THEM TRY TO SKIRT.
THIS RULER TO BASICALLY ON.
NOT TRIGGER THE THRESHOLD RULE
THE FIFTY THE SO CALLED FIFTY
PERCENT RULE.
.
THAT WOULD INCUR THE
REQUIREMENT TO ACTUALLY RAISE
THE HOME UP OUT OF THE ABOUT OF
THE BASE FLOOD ELEVATION.
WITH RECONSTRUCTION AHEAD OF US
I THINK THE SILVER LINING OF
COURSE IS.
IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
BACK BETTER.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF I THINK
REALLY POSITIVE IDEAS AROUND
FUTURE RESILIENCE.
FOR EXAMPLE REINFORCED WALL
SECTIONS.
AS WE JUST DISCUSSED THE
POSSIBILITY OF ELEVATING THE
HOMES AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
STRATEGIES THERE SUCH AS PI LONG
FOUNDATIONS OR REYES FOUNDATIONS
WITH BREAKAWAY WALLS SO THAT
MUCH CAN ACTUALLY FLOW UNDER THE
HOUSE WITHOUT IMPACTING THE
LIVING SPACE.
WITH RELATIVELY MINOR DAMAGE TO
THE.
TO THE BUILDING.
FOR HOMES THAT ARE ARE.
NEARLY COMPLETE OR COMPLETELY
ALLOWS.
RELOCATING THE HOME ON THE
PROPERTY IS ALSO POTENTIALLY AN
OPTION.
AND I I ALSO DON'T WANT TO LET
THE OPPORTUNITY PASS TO TALK
ABOUT THE A CHANCE THAT WE HAVE
TO BUILD BACK.
.
TO HIRE SUSTAINABILITY TARGETS
OR EVEN THAT ZERO ENERGY.
WE DON'T GET THAT MANY
OPPORTUNITIES OVER THE LIFETIME
OF A TYPICAL BUILDING TO WORK
INSIDE OF THE WALLS ARE WORK
INSIDE THE ROOF THE YOU KNOW THE
VARIOUS BUILDING ASSEMBLIES AND.
WHEN WE DO WE CAN REALLY HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY OF THAT BUILDING
ENCLOSURE.
AND AND SO THIS IS A RARE
OPPORTUNITY.
WITH ALL THAT SAID I THINK AGAIN
BE INTENSE COST PRESSURE ON
THESE.
PROJECTS.
.
LEADS ME TO LIMITED OPTIMISM
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF THESE.
.
OF ALL OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES
WITHOUT SOME KIND OF.
SUPPORT PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS.
LIKE TO CLOSE WITH A FINAL
THOUGHT.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO
CLEAR MY HEAD FROM ACROSS SPACE.
ON YOUR BELLY.
IT'S INTENSELY DANGEROUS.
VERY DIRTY FILTHY WET.
PHYSICAL WORK
AND.
.
THE PEOPLE YOU KNOW WORKING AT
OUR CONSTRUCTION HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS.
FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS ON END WITH
A SMILE ON THEIR FACE.
IN ORDER TO REBUILD THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN THIS IS THIS IS
THE REAL HEROISM.
OF THE RECONSTRUCTION EFFORT.
AT THIS POINT I AM VERY PROUD
OF THESE GUYS.
THESE MEN WITH IT FOR DOING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
INTO FAT I'LL LE. ALL UP INTO
QUESTIONS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SCOTT AND I APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR INFORMATION AND I
WERE DEATHLY HEARING THEMES. AND
THAT HAVE COME UP.
FOR BOTH NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL COAST AND.
AB BUT ALSO THEMES THAT ARE BY.
THAT ARE INDEPENDENT OF JUST
REGION BUT ALSO THE KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE AT THE TIMELY IN THE
RECOVERY PROCESS.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS.
AS A MEMBER WALDRON.
.
MY AREA HAD THE LILAC FIRE.
WHICH WASN'T TO THE SCALE
OBVIOUSLY THAT WE SAW HERE BUT.
SAN DIEGO BACK WHEN I SERVED IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE HAD THE
CEDAR FIRE. WHICH HAD TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND ACRES BURN WITH. TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED STRUCTURES
THAT WAS THE FIRST ONE THAT HIT
WHEN I WAS IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND THEN FOLLOWED UP WITH THE
WHICH FIRED IN THE CREEK FIRE.
WHICH HAD ANOTHER.
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES SO WHEN WE LIVED THROUGH
WE LEARNED A LOT WE LEARNED A
LOT BECAUSE WHEN WE HAD THE
LILAC FIRE THIS TIME IT WAS
NIGHT AND DAY. FROM WHAT IT HAD
BEEN AS FAR AS COMMUNICATIONS
JUSTLY INTERAGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS WAS SO MUCH MORE
ADVANCED.
.
YOU KNOW I'M I WAS SPUR GETTING
DAILY UPDATES AND SPEAKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES WE HAD.
YOU CAL FIRE DIDAN AWESOME JOB
A LOCAL FIRE DISTRICTS THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS MUTUAL AID
ALL OF THAT.
.
SOME OF THE THINGS WE LEARNED
THOUGH WAS IT'S NOT ONLY JUST
THE HOMES THAT ACTUALLY BURN
THAT ARE IMPACTED BECAUSE. WITH
THE CEDAR FIRE. AND MAYBE IT WAS
EVEN THE WHICH FIRE WAS WORSE.
THE AMOUNT OF ASH THAT FELL AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW LOOK WAS YOU
KNOW AS FAR AS WITH THE BUT IT
FOR A WEEK THE GROUND WAS
COVERED WITH WHITE ASH AND THEN
WHEN YOU GET THE RAIN. PEOPLE'S
HOMES WERE MILES FROM THE FIRE.
ACTUALLY HAD THE CARP IS
DESTROYED ON YOU THE AIR QUALITY
IMPACTING PEOPLE'S HEALTH WE HAD.
YOU KNOW LOSS OF.
KIDS GOING TO SCHOOL JUST
EVERYTHING COLLAPSED.
AND.
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU I GUESS MY
QUESTION FOR YOU IS THE BUT ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THINGS WE SAW AS
AN IMPROVEMENT. WAS THE
COMMUNICATIONS HOW DID WE GET
ALERTS OUT TO PEOPLE WHERE THE
FIRE IS GOING BACILLI LA FIRE
JUST WITH. VERY QUICKLY ON.
AND THEN AFTERWARDS IN RECOVERY
HOW DO WE GET INFORMATION OUT TO
PEOPLE.
WHERE THEY CAN GO TO AXIS THING
WHAT'S AVAILABLE I MEAN WE HAD
SOME COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND I
KNOW DOCTOR WOODS OFFICES BUT
ALSO BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY WERE
AHEAD OF US? YOU KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN SANTA ROSA THAT WE
COULD THEN PREPARE FOR IN
ADVANCE.
TOM YOU'RE HURT WHAT'S THE BEST
METHODS THAT YOU FOUND TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT.
YOU KNOW.
WHAT'S AVAILABLE HOW CAN THEY
GET THE DEBRIS REMOVAL WHAT YOU
KNOW.
THINGS LIKE THAT.
TYPE I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE REALLY FIGURED OUT IS
WHERE OUR LIMITATIONS ARE ON
COMMUNICATION. IS OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE BEEN HAVING A BIG
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE ALERT
SYSTEM AND WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT IN CINEMA COUNTY.
THE NIGHT OF THE FIRE I THINK
MANY OF US LEARNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF REDUNDANCY FOR INTERNET
AND CELLPHONES IN AREAS OF OUR
CITY THAT MAYBE. SOMEWHERE NOT
AS AWARE OF AND THE FLOW OF
INFORMATION WAS SLOW AS A RESULT
OF THAT. WE ARE WORKING ON.
PICKING THAT UP AND TRYING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
ONE OF THE FEW PLACES THAT I'D
BE CRITICAL OF THE RESPONSE THAT
WE'VE SEEN IS YOU WOULD THINK
THAT HAVING GONE THROUGH
MULTIPLE FIRES THROUGH. MUD
SLIDES THAT THERE WOULD BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION IN
TERMS OF ONE PAGERS THAT WE
COULD PUT OUT TO THE PUBLIC. FOR
THEM TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PROCESS LOOKS LIKE PARTICULARLY
FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL AND.
THAT WASN'T THERE AND WASN'T
AVAILABLE WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
WE HAVE IT NOW WE HAVE WEBSITES
UP AND WE AS A COMMUNITY HAVE
GOT MUCH BETTER ABOUT PUSHING
INFORMATION. TO OUR NEIGHBORS.
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
DON'T LEAVE HERE. TALKING ABOUT
OUR ALERT SYSTEM WITHOUT. ALSO
MENTIONING HOW INCREDIBLE IT WAS
NEIGHBORS HELPING NEIGHBORS
THROUGHOUT THE FIRE THAT THAT
WAS OUR ALERT SYSTEM. AND IT'S
BOTH A FAILURE FROM A GOVERNMENT
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO A SUCCESS
FROM A COMMUNITY PERSPECTIVE AND
NOT TO MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN THOSE STRUCTURES AS
WELL.
EIGHTY HAVE A FOLLOW UP ON THAT
POINT.
MISS WALDRON IS.
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THAT.
SIGN.
IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT TO. MEASURE
THE EFFECTIVENESS BUT I ALSO
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT SOME PEOPLE MAY NOT PAY
ATTENTION TO THEIR CELLPHONES OR
HOW THEM OFF AT NIGHT. OR MAY
NOT BE AWARE OF WHAT'S.
BUT NO THIS LARGE MIGHT BE IN
THAT IN FACT.
YOU KNOW WITH THE LACK OF SIRENS
WERE YOU KNOW WE OF SOME FLOOD
SIRENS WHERE I LIVE BUT.
.
THAT THAT NEIGHBOR NEIGHBOR
CONTACT WAS THAT VOICE OF
URGENCY THAT THIS IS REAL AND
YOU ACTUALLY NEED TO GET UP OUT
OF YOUR COMFORTABLE HOME.
BECAUSE DANGER IS IMMINENT.
WHEREAS YOU KNOW WE KIND OF GET
THESE ALERTS SOMETIMES AND IT'S
A BIT MORE PASSIVE.
AND DATA AND THAT THAT ALONE.
DID YOU KNOW THE FUTURE WOULDN'T
GIVE PEOPLE THAT THAT SAME SENSE
OF URGENCY NOW YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT ANYTHING THAT YOU DO EVEN
ON THE ALERT SIZE IF IT'S A
SIREN. YOU STILL HAVE TO HAVE A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AROUND WHAT
THOSE SIRENS MEAN JUST SENDING
OFF AN ALARM WITHOUT THE PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY'RE
INTENDED TO DO WHERE THEY CAN GO
AND FIND MORE INFORMATION. WOULD
CREATE PANIC IF YOU HAVEN'T
PREPARED THE COMMUNITY ON HOW TO
RESPOND TO THAT SIREN SO I THINK
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT IT FROM TWO DIFFERENT
ANGLES. ONE IS ON THE TECHNOLOGY
SIDE BUT THEM ONE IS STILL
HIGHLIGHTING ON THE COMMUNITY
SIDE.
SOME JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP ARM
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT ISSUE ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE
ENCOUNTERED AFTER THOSE BIG
FIRES IN THE MID.
A TWO THOUSANDS WAS.
YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE THEN COULDN'T GET
INSURANCE
I MEAN I WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WE COULD NOT GET INSURANCE I WAS
ON THE FAIR PLAN AND MY WAY SAID
THE FAIR PLAYING ISN'T FAIR.
BECAUSE. THE AVERAGE COST IS
MORE THAN DOUBLE WHAT THE MARKET
RATE WOULD BE FOR A HOME AND IF
YOU CAN'T GET INSURANCE THEN.
PEOPLE WILL WALKING AWAY FROM
THEIR HOMES. SO HOW DO WE.
THAT
YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING I
GUESS WE'RE ALL GOING TO HAVE TO
WORK ON BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW THEY SAY HI FIRE RISK
AREAS NOW THERE. MY DISTRICT IS
IN YOUR ALL YOUR DISTRICTS WILL
BE IF THEY'RE NOT ALREADY.
I'M GONNA HAVE.
WHEN NEW HOMES BUILT ON MORAL
ENCOURAGING YOU KNOW
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND BUILDING.
HOW ARE THEY GONNA GET INSURED
AND THE FAIR PLAN REALLY IS
VERY DIFFICULT FOR? HAS NO
AFFORDABILITY THERE AND IT'S
JUST BASIC.
COVERAGE IT REALLY DOESN'T COVER
MUCH SO. I JUST WANTED TO KIND
OF PUT THAT OUT THERE FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
IF IF I MAY THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
WRITTEN AND BLOOMBERG THAT
TALKED ABOUT.
IT WAS CHALLENGING US IN SAYING
ARE WE SUBSIDIZING PEOPLE A
REPAIRMAN FILE UP FIRE AREAS.
RIGHT NOW IT'S WHAT WE ALL HAVE
TO LOOK OUT FOR IS IS AS WE DO
THAT IS BECAUSE YOU WANT
AFFORDABILITY BUT AT THE SAME
TIME. IF SOMEBODY THINKS THAT IN
THE FUTURE THEY CAN LIVE IN A
FIRE AREA AND HAVE LOK LOW
INSURANCE COVERAGE AND HAVE
GREAT RESULTS IT'S NOT THERE. IF
YOU LOOK IN KEY WEST I HAD A
CHANCE.
TO GOT TO KEY WEST IMPORTER
RICO'S APART A DISASTER TOURS
KEEP FOLKS IN KEY WEST PAY MORE
ON.
INSURANCE THEY DO ON THEIR
MORTGAGE
RIGHT. ARE NOT NOT KEY WEST THE
KEYS RIGHT NOW HAVE A A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT INSURANCE THAT
BUNDLE AROUND IT AND. IN THAT IF
YOU LOOK ON THE OTHER SIDE IT'S
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE HEARING IS
IS THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS INSURANCE COMPANIES
ARE DROPPING OUT OF THESE AREAS
AND SO YOU HAVE GROUPS LIKE.
WITH IT WHAT'S REFERRED TO AS
LOW TO LONDON. WHICH IS
BASICALLY A RISK POOL BY
INVESTORS THAT THEY PUT INTO AN
AREA IT'S NOT REALLY AN
INSURANCE.
PROGRAM IT'S IT IT'S A RISK
PROGRAM THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
TO BUNDLE IT. BUT I THINK YOUR
QUESTION BEFORE IS WHAT IS TRUE
RESILIENCE AND THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD I WOULD ASK YOU ALL TO.
COME TO HELP US CONSIDER AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS NUMBER
ONE IN SAN DIEGO WE NEED TO
LEARN THE LESSON THE POWER DOWN
GRITS.
RIGHT. NOW WHICH ARE LINKED WITH
NATURAL WEATHER SERVICE
ANOTHER'S NUMBER TWO OAKLAND
HILLS UNDERGROUND IN SPECIFIC
AREAS LINKED WITH THE SIREN
SYSTEM THAT HAD TRAINING THEY
STILL HAVE THOSE CERTEON IS OUT
THERE. THAT ARE MANAGING A A
SIREN SYSTEM IN THERE DOING
OTHER THINGS.
THREE CAMERA SYSTEMS INFRARED
CAMERA SYSTEMS THAT WOULD IT'S
LOOKING LIKE WE'RE APPLYING FOR.
OF THE FEMUR HAZARD MITIGATION
GRANT PROGRAM TO DO TWO TO THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN INFRARED FIRE
CAMERA CYCLE ON TOP OF AN
EXISTING ANTENNA ARRAY. IN OUR
AREA THAT'S DEPLOYED IN RENO
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO ALSO REDUCE
THE COSTS OF OF OF WHEN A CALL
COMES IN ITS FIREFIGHTERS HAVING
TO GO CHECK EVERYTHING.
NUMBER FOUR.
IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD ALREADY THEN
THE P. JEANNIE SHOULD BE TELLING
YOU WHAT WHAT THEY'RE PLANNING
WITH THEIR FIRE SEASON IN THEIR
TIER THREE AREAS. THERE LOOKING
TO DO FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN FEET
ON EACH SIDE. BY IN BETWEEN NOW
AND REALLY SEPTEMBER IN OUR
AREAS AND THROUGHOUT MANY OF
YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND GOING IN AND.
IN REMOVING ALL THAT BRUSH
INSTEAD OF LEAVING IT LIKE THEY
DID BEFORE. AND SO YOU LOOK
THROUGH THESE THINGS AND THEN
WHAT WOULD WE NEED TO DO WELL WE
NEED TO HAVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ORDINANCES.
YOU KNOW THAT ARE JUST FOCUSED
ON LITTLE POPULATION AREAS BUT
IF YOU'RE AN ABSENTEE LANDOWNERS
AND SOME OF THE AREAS IN ARE
DISTRICTS AND YOU DON'T HAVE
GRAZING AND YOU DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW PRESCRIBED BURNING OR
OTHER STUFF YOUR PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHT IT GETS
CONFLICTING AGAINST YOUR PRIVATE
PROPERTY RESPONSIBILITY. SO JUST
FINAL THING IS IN IN YOU'D
LEADERSHIP UNLIKE COUNTING WITH
YOU ALL.
AS I MET WITH SOME OF YOUR FOLKS
WHO THERE THAT THE ONE AREA LEFT
TO BURN THERE IS A BETWEEN HOP
FLUENT. IN THE LAKE AND SO THEY
HAVE A NINE THOUSAND ACRE
PRESCRIBED BURN THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO GO AFTER TIME AND
AGAIN AND THEY HAVE THE PERMITS
FOR. INTO TRYING TO FIND THE
RIGHT THING FOR IT RIGHT SO
THEY'RE LEADING THE CHARGE EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE BEHIND ON
RESOURCES.
AND I THINK WE NEED THE YOU KNOW
AS A PART OF OUR WORK WITH CAL
FIRE AND OTHERS. IS WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT THIS WORLD OF I WOULD
ASK YOU ALL TO HELP US.
IT IS IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT MONEY
IT'S HELPING US WITH THE PERMITS
ON ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS
WHETHER IT BACH MED. OR NORTHERN
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF GHGS FROM
LIKE WHEN.
GRACE BENNETT AND JUDY. MORRIS
FROM TRINITY AND SISKIYOU EVEN
KICK STATE OF JEFFERSON FOLKS
ARE LIKE WE DON'T EVEN AGREE
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE EXISTS BUT
WE DO AGREE THAT IN THESE MOST
RECENT RASH OF FIRES. WE
RELEASED BOARD GHGS INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE THAT WE COULD OF OVER
OVER THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS.
SO THINGS LIKE THAT MEAN WE
DON'T WANT SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
THAT SCARE US.
YOU OR SCARE YOU ALL BUT STUFF
LIKE THAT WHERE YOU CAN DO GOOD
IS DESPERATELY NEED.
AND HERE I THINK TO ALL OF YOUR
POINTS AND YOU YOU EACH TALK
ABOUT SCALING UP RIGHT AND.
OR IN SOME WAY ABOUT WE'VE SEEN
THIS IS THIS ISN'T JUST ONE CITY
ONE COUNTY THIS IS MUCH BIGGER
AND WERE ALL RUNNING ACROSS THE
SAME THEMES. ANTS AT SOME OF
WHAT YOU'VE TOUCHED ON IS
REFLECTED IN THIS HANDOUT THAT
WAS GIVEN WITH.
FORTY BILLS US SORRY FORTY FOUR
AND COUNTING. FLAT A FORTY FOUR
BILLS IN ACCOUNTING. AND THAT
HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED I THINK
THAT THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED ON IN
TERMS OF IMPACTING SOME OF THESE
AREAS WHETHER YOU DESCRIBE THE
INSURANCE.
THE DEBRIS REMOVAL WHICH HAS
BECOME AN EVERYDAY WORD FOR ALL
OR TERM FOR ALL OF US AND.
I. MANAGEMENT PLAN STATEWIDE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT IMPACT
TO THE ENVIRONMENT BUT THE TRADE
OFFS I THINK ALL OF THAT IS
REFLECTED IN AND IN MOST OF
THESE BILLS. UP BUT YOU DO
EMPHASIZE THE POINT OVER AND
OVER THAT AT THIS ISN'T JUST
APPLYING TO ONE AREA THAT THIS
IS BROADER I'M I WAS STRUCK BY.
THE DESCRIPTION OF THE WATERSHED
MARINES.
THAT AND THE FACT THAT.
DOT IS ONE EXAMPLE OF AREAS
WHERE I THINK ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES COULD HAVE DONE
BETTER I KNOW THAT I RECEIVED
CALLS FROM NAG.
SAYING WE WANT REALLY BASIC
THINGS AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO TO
GO TO SOMEONE SAYS IT'S.
THE.
YEAH CAN YOU KNOW THAT RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS OTHER
FOLKS A KNOW ITS FEMALE AND NO
IT'S THE COUNTY AND AND. WHAT
ARE THE STATE WE WERE GOING BACK
AND FORTH BUT I THINK YOU'VE
RAISED THE IDEA THAT REALLY WE
DO HAVE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT?
THE SCALE OF THIS AND WHO TO GO
TO.
AND WHAT'S THE RIGHT ENTITY BUT
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THERE
WERE. I MEAN WITH THE LIST CAN
GO ON A ON WHETHER IT'S AN ALARM
SYSTEM OUR NOTIFICATION SYSTEM.
WATERSHEDS.
CON I THINK WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THE LABOR MARKET AND
CONTRACTING AND EVERYONE'S
TALKED ABOUT INSURANCE.
IN THIS.
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE'S
THERE'S THERE'S SOME WORK TO BE
DONE BUT I I HOPE THAT IN THESE
FORTY FOUR BILLS AND COUNTING.
ON THE IS THAT SOME OF THAT IS
REFLECTED IN IN THIS.
AS I'M A WOOD. YET THEN THESE
ARE KIND OF A.
THE DIVERSION FROM SOME WERE
TALKING ABOUT BUT I'M I'M
THINKING SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE
HERE AS FAR AS WHAT SOME OF THE
MORE LONG TERM EFFECTS AS WELL
AND THAT'S.
I COME WITH YOU KNOW FROM BOTH
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY IN AND THEN
SNOW COUNTY. THAT THE THE NUMBER
OF HOMES
THAT ARE OR ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LEFT THE AREA.
AND HOW MANY ARE HOW MANY WE
LOST.
AND THEN AND THEN ALSO.
IF SOMEONE CAN SUCH ON THE WHAT
WHAT WHAT I'M WILL ALL REFER TO
AS SORT OF THE SECONDARILY
DISPLACED FOLKS THE FOLKS THAT.
JUST.
GOT BOOTED OUT QUITE FRANKLY.
WHAT SANTA BARBARA COUNTY ARE
IMPACT IS LARGE OBVIOUSLY AS
CINEMA BUT LIKE I SAID OVER?
FIVE HUNDRED WHERE I AM DAMJAN
ASTRIDE NAY THINK EHRLICH TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN WERE RED TAGGED
AND SO YOU SEE SOME OF THAT
STILL UP THERE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
MOVED BACK.
AND.
IN THIS AREA WE THE PEOPLE OF
CHOICES.
AND SO THE WORRY THAT WE HAVE IS
NOT GOING TO WANT TO MOVE BACK
AND IF THEY DON'T TO GO THROUGH
THE ISSUES THAT.
.
I JUST TALKED ABOUT THAT SO THAT
OTHER WORRY AND SO TRYING TO
KEEP THE COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND
ENGAGED.
BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
COME TO COMMUNITY MEETINGS I
KNOW I WANT TO REBUILD. I WANT
TO STAY HERE AND SO IT'S REALLY
DEPENDING IT'S TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGED ON THE SECONDARY.
ISSUES WE ARE EXPERIENCE ARE
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
WE HAVE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WORKS.
DISTRICTS STRUGGLING TO RENTING
COURSE SERVING THAT COMMUNITY
AND SO THEY'VE BEEN DISPLACED IN
THEIR JOBS.
.
PEOPLE THINK THAT IT'S JUST A
VERY SHE SHE AREA IT IS BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF SERVICE WORKERS
AS WELL AND SO WE'RE SEEING A
LOT INCOME THROUGH OUR RECOVERY
CENTER. I'M LOOKING FOR ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE.
AND THAT CONTINUES TO BE A
STRUGGLE FOR US WE'VE ALL THE
SBA LOANS AND ALL THE FEMA
INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE ALL OF
THAT HAS OCCURRED. WE HAD.
R. BLATTNER PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITY GIVEN MONEY TO OUR
UNITED WAY AND THEY'RE RELEASING
THAT MONEY IN THAT PURE
DISCLOSED PRESS AGAINST WE'VE
DONE ANOTHER SURGE OF TRYING TO
APPLICATIONS OUT. BUT IT IS A
STRUGGLE.
THE ON THE NUMBER SIDE IS TWO
THINGS THAT. YOU KNOW WERE
FORCED TO KIND OF USE MACRO
NUMBERS TO TRYING TO ESTIMATE
TOO OFTEN. LIKE FOR INSTANCE THE
FACT THAT ONLY TWENTY NINE
PERCENT OF RENTERS HAVE
UNTIL ENSURE.
IN THE CINEMA COUNTY MODEL AND
SO.
SECONDLY IS THE FACT THAT IN
BOTH IN IN IN THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE AREA THIRTY NINE PERCENT
OF THE ENTIRE HOMES LOST FIFTY
THREE HUNDRED. WERE.
WERE RENTERS AS WELL RIGHT SO
THE RENTERS AS IT WAS DESCRIBED
TO US BY SOME OF THE FEMALE
HOUSING FOLKS. IT'S VERY HARD TO
TRACK THEM
BECAUSE THEY KIND OF PEOPLE WHO
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIKE COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
RENTERS THEY ARE FULL TIME HOME
RENTERS RIGHT. SO THEY KIND OF
MOVE AND I MEAN IT WAS FUNNY TO
HEAR ME EVEN TALK ABOUT OF THE
FEMA HOUSING SPECIALIST.
A ONE THING I DO WANT TO SAY IS
THAT MIGHT BE INTERESTING TO YOU
ALL IS. WERE WORKING WITH ONE OF
THE FOUNDATIONS AND CINEMA
COUNTY RIGHT NOW TO DO PRETTY
VERY EXPENSIVE AND COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY TO TRACK THAT SO IT CAN
AND FORMER DECISION MAKING. THIS
IS NOT THE TIPPING POINT ONE BUT
IT'S SIMILAR TO THAT THAT THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY BRING IN A
RESEARCH GROUP THAT TO TRY AND
HELP US. WITH LIKE TO BEGIN NO
ON TIME DECISION MAKING THAT
THIS IS HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING BECAUSE AS YOU SAID IT'S
IS. ONLY AS ONLY ANECDOTAL ONCE
AGAIN BUT PERSONALLY I'VE HAD AT
LEAST FIFTEEN PEOPLE CONTACT MY
OFFICE.
WHICH MIGHT SEEM LIKE A LOW
NUMBER BUT LET'S SAY ONE OUT OF
EVERY.
FIFTY OR A HUNDRED DECIDES TO
CONTACT A GOVERNMENT OFFICE
TO SAY I'VE BEEN I'VE HAD TO
MOVE OUT OF MY HOME BECAUSE
EITHER THE LANDLORDS WHO LOST
HER HOME MOVED BACK. OR THE
INSURANCE HERE'S THE THING
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE PAYING IN BETWEEN
SIX AND TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH TO HOUSE PEOPLE.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NOT PAYING
PEOPLE BACK.
AT A HIGH LEVEL FOR REBUILD THEY
SEE THEY HAVE A HUGE LIABILITY
IF THEY DON'T FIND YOU HOUSING
LOCALLY.
SO THE PAIN NOT MUCH IN ITS
FORCING THIS OUT AND SO WE HAD A
WOMAN WHO WAS A. IT WAS AT THE
CATTLEMEN'S
WHAT IS A HOSTESS AT THE
CATTLEMEN'S WHO GLENN JULY TO
GOD REST HIS SOUL CALLS ME UP
AND SAYS. A MATTER THE OTHER
NIGHT SHE'S THE HOSTESS THERE
AND SHE CAN AFFORD. PROBABLY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED BUCKS A MONTH.
SLEEP IN HER CAR IN FRONT OF A
QUE WAY RIGHT. I KNOW THAT'S
ANECDOTAL BUT IT IS HAPPENING.
SO.
.
LEARNED SO MUCH BUT THE QUESTION
IS HOW DO WE WORK WITH YOU GUYS
TO SPREAD THIS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. A FINAL THING IS WHEN WE
MET TO REVIEW OUR INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENT DONE BY.
YES ON OUR.
ON OUR LEARNING SYSTEM.
BY DIRECTOR KILLER DUDE SHE AND
TWO OF HIS OTHER FOLKS SAID THEY
SAID YOU GOTTA REALIZE THAT WE
DID A STATEWIDE SURVEY AND I
NEVER HEARD OF THIS AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ABOUT
PREPAREDNESS. AND LIKE MORE THAN
FIFTY PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
DON'T DON'T EVEN REACH THE FIRST
ROUND OF PREPAREDNESS WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S RISK
IN THEIR LIVES. YOU KNOW SO THEY
SAID THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO
KIND OF SAY NOBODY'S PREPARED
FOR THIS AND YET WE'RE IN THE
NEW NORMAL.
AND SO NO MATTER WHAT WE DO WITH
WIRELESS ALERTS AND OTHER THINGS.
WE GOT TO GET BACK TO BASICS SO
ON HELP US HELP YOU FIGURE THAT
OUT. FED THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ASKING THE
THE QUESTION BECAUSE THAT'S ONE
OF THE PARTS OF. THIS
CONVERSATION THAT TENDS TO GET
LOST FROM THE CITY AND FROM THE
COUNTY PERSPECTIVE IS WERE
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME FOCUSING
ON HOW TO HELP THE FOLKS THAT
LOST THEIR HOMES. AND NOT.
AND NOT ENOUGH TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE MACRO EFFECTS THAT'S
HAVING IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE'VE
DONE A SURVEY BY THE OR THE
UNITED POLICY HOLDERS HAVE DONE
A SURVEY THAT SHOWED ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THE FOLKS THAT LOST
THEIR HOMES. IN THE FIRE.
WERE UNDER INSURED BY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ON
AVERAGE.
AND WE EXPECT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
A THIRD TO A HALF TO NOT REBUILD.
THERE ARE MANY HAVE MOVED
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY.
MANY HAVE LEFT AND I KNOW OUR
SCHOOL BOARD IS A LITTLE BIT
TERRIFIED THAT WHEN THE SCHOOL
YEAR IS OVER AND THE KIDS ARE NO
LONGER HOLDING THE FAMILIES
THERE THAT THAT'S WHEN WE'LL SEE
DISPLACEMENT AS WELL. BUT OVER
ALSO SAYING IS FOR
BECAUSE WE IN SANTA ROSA HAVE
LESS THAN A ONE PERCENT VACANCY
RATE FOR RENTERS. RANCHERS ARE
BEING DISPLACED BY FOLKS WHO
INSURANCE WILL PAY MORE FOR.
AND OTHERS WHO WERE LIVING ON
THE MARGINS A RIGHT BETWEEN
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD A PLACE TO
LIVE IN BEING LIVING IN THEIR
CAR ARE ALSO BEING PUSHED
FURTHER OUT AND SO WE'VE SEEN
RANCHERS DISPLACED WE'VE SEEN. A
MORE OF A HOMELESS BOOM AND
SANTA ROSA IN PARTICULAR THAT WE
HAD BEFORE THESE WERE ISSUES
THAT WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH. AND
THEN JUST SORT ABOUT THE LAST
NOTED THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS POINT
ABOUT US ALL TALKING ABOUT THIS
AS A REGIONAL ISSUE I SERVE ON
THE MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS
LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE. ONE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM EACH CITY IN
THE COUNTY AND WE DON'T MEET AT
ALL ANYMORE WITHOUT ME HEARING
FROM THOSE COUNCIL MEMBERS ABOUT
HOW WE ARE SUCKING IN. RESOURCES
INTO SANTA ROSA THAT ARE ALSO
MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
COMPLETE THEIR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS
THAT WERE ALREADY UNDER WAY OR
WERE GETTING UNDER WAY. SO IT'S
NOT JUST SAN AROSE IT'S NOT JUST
THE COUNTY OF CINEMA BUT REALLY
A REGIONAL PROBLEM THAT'S
DISPLACING FOLKS AND PREVENTING
US FROM BEING ABLE TO BUILD THE
LIMITED HOUSING WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PERMIT.
IS FOR US MISTER KNIPE OREGON.
.
IN MISMATCHED MINNESOTA'S WELL
ON.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY WITH THE
SOME MEMBER LIMON TURNED TOWARD
MINUS YOU KNOW AND BILLY WAS FOR
SMALL IMPRESSED ABOUT THE COUNTY
OPERATION THAT YOU HAD AT YOUR
FOLLOWER. HOUSE AND THE PUSH OUT
OF.
.
SOCIAL WORKERS IN PARTICULAR
OPTICALLY FOR FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN USED TO ASKING FOR
HELP OR DIDNOT KNOW HOW TO.
ORGANIZE AND PRIORITIZE
HOW TO DO THAT. AFTER NOT
NEEDING TO ASK FOR HELP FOR A
LOT OF THEIR LIVES AND I WAS
IMPRESSED BY THAT ALSO.
FRIGHTENED BY THE FACT THAT THAT
WAS THE DAY THAT THE FEMA CREW
PACKED UP AND LEFT. AND I
THOUGHT I ALREADY BECAUSE ON
THAT TOUR.
.
IT'S REALLY AYE OPENING FOR FOR
SOMEONE THAT REPRESENTS IN THE
COUNTY THAT TO GO DOWN THERE AND
SEE WHAT. THAT THE DESTRUCTION
WAS LIKE THERE SO WE SAW A LOT
OF IMAGES.
WHERE HOMES?
LOOKED BEAUTIFUL THERE THERE
MAYBE IS A.
A LINE OF WHERE.
THE MUD SLIDE WENT TWO
SOMETIMES I THINK IT WAS ABOVE
OUR HEADS.
YEAH. AND AS I YOU KNOW WALKED
IN APPROACHED THE WINDOW OF ONE
OF THE HOMES I REALIZED HOW HIGH
I WAS.
IT WAS LOOKING DOWN INTO THE
WINDOW.
AND THAT WHEN I WAS LOOKING
DOWN INTO THE WINDOW THAT THE
MUD WAS KITCHEN COUNTER DEPTH
HIGH.
AND.
AND SO YOU MIGHT LOOK.
YOU KNOW FRONT FROM ANOTHER.
PERSPECTIVE OF WHILE THE HOMES
ARE STILL OUT.
NO WHAT IS WHAT'S THE ISSUE
WHERE IT WHERE YOU KNOW IT WE
WANT TO COPY PARK IN SANTA ROSA
AND THERE'S IT'S LIKE A WAR
FIELD.
ABOUT FIELD BUT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW ANYONE
RECOVERS FROM AT YOU KNOW ONE
HOW DID THE MIGHT FIND ITS WAY
INTO THE HOME SO PERFECTLY LIKE
IT WAS BUILT THEIR DOOR OPENED
AND THEY WERE JUST GIVEN A TOUR.
AND.
IN IT IS THAT IS THAT REALLY A
AT THAT HOUSE TOTALED BUT IS
THERE A WAY TO REMEDIAL EIGHT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BECAUSE WE
WAS MANY MONTHS LATER IS MAYBE
FOUR MONTHS LATER THAT WE DID
THAT TOUR. AND HOMEOWNER GAVE US
THE TOUR.
AND.
I WANT TO KNOW WHERE TO START OF
COURSE.
YEAH SO CAN GIVE US A SENSE
ABOUT THAT SO SO YOU KNOW US
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OR
MEMBERS ARE NOT FROM SANTA
BARBARA CAN GET A SENSE OF THE
SCALE OF THAT THAT DESTRUCTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
THE QUESTION IT'S A GOOD ONE.
.
IT'S DE THAT IS SO EVEN WHEN THE
HOUSE IS THREE OR FOUR FEET DEEP
IN MUD AND DEBRIS.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
VALUE THERE THAT CAN BE SALVAGED
SO THE FOUNDATION THE FRAME.
.
IN MANY CASES WHAT WE CALL THE
ANY PIECE OF MECHANICAL
ELECTRICAL AND PLUMBING SYSTEMS
ARE ARE ARE DAMAGED BUT
DEFINITELY.
REPAIRABLE.
THE STILL REFUND THE BUILDING
AT THE ROOF DOESN'T LEAK.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT DOORS
AND WINDOWS.
HAVE NOT BEEN IMPACTED BY THEM
I DO KNOW THAT THE BUDGET FOR MY
DIDN'T GET THAT HIGH WORTH MIGHT
HIT ONE SIDE OF THE BUILDING BUT
NOT THE OTHER.
AND YOU KNOW THOSE ARE ALL
EXAMPLES OF MAJOR COSTS.
IN THE IN THE OVERALL VALUE OF
THE BUILDING.
.
WHICH.
BY RAISING THE BUILDING
ENTIRELY WE WOULD WE WOULD. THEN
BE FORCED TO REPLACE.
.
OUR OUR ABILITY TO CONSIDER THAT
OPTION IT IS FURTHER LIMITED BY
THE FACT THAT WHEN THE INSURANCE
CARRIER SEES THAT VALUE.
PRESERVED ON THE PROPERTY THEY
WILL NOT SUPPORT.
IT YOU KNOW THINK THAT CLAIM
INCLUDING THE REPLACEMENT.
OF THAT VALUE AND SO AND IN MANY
WAYS WE HAVE A CHOICE BUT TO
SALVAGE WHATEVER PARTS THE
BUILDING WE CAN BECAUSE. WE CAN
ONLY GET BE OUR RESOURCES IN THE
FORM OF AN INSURANCE SETTLEMENT.
TO REPLACE WHAT HAS TRULY BEEN
DAMAGED.
.
THAT BEING SAID.
TO REMOVE.
OF A BUILDING FROM THE
LANDSCAPE ENTIRELY IS THE CHORE
OF A PIECE OF HEAVY MACHINERY TO
REMOVE THREE FEET ABOUT FROM THE
INSIDE OF THE HOUSE WHILE
LEAVING THE HOUSE AND TAX IS THE
CHORE OF. A GROUP OF TWENTY MEN
AND WOMEN WITH SHOVELS AND
WHEELBARROWS.
AND SO IT'S IT'S A CHALLENGE TO
SAY THE LEAST ARE ALSO POINT OUT
TO YOU.
JUST TO.
AGAINST HAVE A SIZE AND ON YOUR
SURPRISE.
.
AT THE WAY THAT THAT NIGHT HAS
FOUND ITS WAY INTO THE BUILDING.
MOTHERS FOUND ITS WAY INTO THE
BUILDING ASSEMBLIES AND MANY
CASES SO WE HAVE FOUND MUD
INSIDE OF WALL CAVITIES.
WE FOUND THAT MUD HAS GOTTEN.
INTO THE WEEK SCREED WHICH OF
THE YOU KNOW THE WE'VE HOLES FOR.
MOISTURE TO ESCAPE FROM STUCCO
CITING.
SUMMIT HAS FLOWED DE UNIVERSE
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE WEED
SCREED AND INFILTRATED BEHIND
THE STUCCO.
BETWEEN THE BUILDING PAPER ON
THE STUCCO BETWEEN BILLION PAPER
IN THE FRAMING.
.
BECAUSE JUST ABOUT ANYWHERE THAT
YOU CAN IMAGINE WE FOUND BY THEN
ELECTRICAL JUNCTION BOXES.
INSIDE OF.
PLUMBING PIPES AND SO THERE'S
THIS REALLY.
QUITE A LOT OF DETAIL WORK THAT
COMES ABOUT WHEN.
WE JUST TO SALVAGE THE BUILDING
SO IT'S IT'S BOTH.
I THINK A BLESSING AND A CURSE.
THAT.
THAT THESE BUILDINGS AREN'T
TOTAL LOSSES.
BUT WOULD YOU REALLY RUN THE
NUMBERS YOU FIND THAT THOSE.
THAT THAT THAT THAT VALUE.
IN MANY CASES IS ABSOLUTELY
WORTH PRESERVING.
SO ESSENTIAL YOU CAN BRING IT
DOWN OF THE STATS.
TATE OR TAKE THE CITING OFF OF
THE BUILDING.
IT YEAH THAT'S IN IN SHORT.
WE CAN OFTEN WE WE CAN OFTEN
CUT YOU KNOW ONE OR TWO FEET
ABOVE THE FLOOD LINE.
.
AND SELL EITHER IS HOMES HAVE
DRY WALL YOU KNOW FROM THREE OR
FOUR FEET UP.
BUT YOU KNOW FROM THERE DOWN
THERE OPEN STUDS.
THERE'S A.
A CLEANING AND SANITATION
PROTOCOL.
THAT GOES TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BUILDING.
FRAME IS FREE OF CONTAMINANTS
AND BACTERIAL.
.
GROWTH AND SO ON.
BEFORE WE CAN PUT THE BUILDING
BACK TOGETHER.
AND THAT IS THAT IS I WOULD SAY.
BY AND LARGE THE STEP THAT THAT
WE'VE WE'VE JUST COMPLETED BUT
MOST OF THESE PROJECTS AND SO
IT'S IT'S BEEN THAT LONG IN
COMING.
MEDIUM PARA WE HAVE ALL OF THE
INSURANCE TO GO SHE SINCE THE
PERMANENT CHALLENGES THAT I WAS.
DISCUSSING BUT.
IT'S A IT'S A PAINSTAKING
PROCESS AND AND VERY LABOR
INTENSIVE.
.
TO SET ASIDE WAS IMPRESSED BY
THAT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
STRUCTURES GIVEN. THE SPEED AND
FORCE BY WHICH THAT MUD SLOWED
DOWN.
THE HILL AND IN AND OUT DOWN
THAT ROAD.
YET I THINK THERE'S SOME LESSONS.
IN RESILIENCE THEIR.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE MANY EXAMPLES
OF.
.
YOU KNOW ONE HOUSE SAVING
ANOTHER. OR A GARDEN WALL OR
EVEN A FENCE LINE.
SAVING HOUSE.
OF SUBSIDED I KNOW THAT MANY
THE COUNTY PLANNERS ARE AT HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS.
AROUND TAMANA SEAT OF BECOMING
A WALLED CITY.
IF FROM HERE ON OUT AND THERE
ARE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S CERTAIN TYPES
OF GARDEN WALLS THAT CAN BE
BUILT WITHOUT.
TENDING OVERSIGHT AND PLANNING
REVIEW.
.
AND SO HOMEOWNERS HAVE A CERTAIN
FREEDOM THERE THAT MAY END UP.
COMING BACK AND AND BITING US
AS A COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE CAN
ONLY CHANNEL LIES.
FUTURE TO PROPOSED SAID SO.
THOUGHT YOU TO SUCH AN EXTENT
BEFORE IT BECOMES A REAL.
A COMPLICATED PROBLEM YEAH
THERE'S ALSO THE RANDOMNESS OF.
THE HOME NEXT DOOR ACROSS THE
STREET IS COMPLETELY UNTOUCHED
WHILE THE OTHER HOMES ALL HAD
THE BIG BOULDERS. JUST PARKED
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE YARD.
YEAH.
THE LEADING ABOUT THE PHYSICS
OF OF DEBRIS FLOWS.
BUT
BUT THEY ARE VERY DISCREET YOU
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
STRUCTURE TO THEM AND HEIGHT AND
SO THE.
KNOWS THE PREFLIGHT MOVE
THROUGH TOWN AS A AS A AS A
DISCREET. YOU KNOW FLOW AND AND
DEFINITE HAD BOUNDARIES SO. IF I
GIVES ADD REALLY QUICK SO ON THE
MUD.
THE ONE THING ABOUT MONEY CEO IN
A LOT OF AREAS WHERE. AN ENTIRE
IT'S AN ALLUVIAL FAN.
THAT'S THAT RIGHT SO THAT THE
THE DEBRIS HAS COME DOWN OVER
HUNDREDS OF YEARS AND SPREAD OUT.
A FAN.
MODESTY WAS BUILT ON THAT.
SO YOU SEE THESE BIG BOULDERS IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY ROCKY NICK
PARK IT'S BECAUSE A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO THERE ISN'T THE
BEHOLDERS CAME DOWN. SO THE MUD
AS OUR OWN OUR OEM DIRECTOR SAYS.
I'M ALL MOUNDS ONE TO BECOME
BEACHES.
THE TO THE SOIL ON THE MAT WANTS
TO COME DOWN AND FLOW TO THE TO
THE OCEAN SO. HARD THAT IS.
IF THE DIFFICULT LESSON FOR ALL
OF US BUT THAT IS TRUE IT'S IT'S
A SYSTEM ALLUVIAL FAN THAT'S HOW
IT.
IT'S BEEN DEVELOPED OVER TIME SO
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE CAN.
NECESSARILY STOP UNFORTUNATELY.
YES DOT ANOTHER POINT MR DE HAS
HAD DEPART. BY TODD YOU KNOW YOU
TALK ABOUT.
TWENTY PEOPLE WHEELBARROWS. SOME
REALLY.
HARD LABOR.
THAT PEOPLE ARE DOING IN IN
DIFFICULT SPACES.
HOW IS IT THAT IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
RECRUIT THAT LABOR?
HOW'S THAT GOING.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
.
LABOR IS A VERY SCARCE RESOURCE
RIGHT NOW.
SO WITH A.
AND WITH RESPECT THE JONES
COMMENTS HAS NOT BEEN ARE BOOTS
ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE.
.
YOU NO RECOGNIZING AS WELL THAT
THAT THE TYPE OF LABOR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS IT'S NOT A HIGH
SKILL.
TOOK TO RUN A SHOVEL.
AND AND AND FRANKLY WITH
HONESTY.
.
THAT TYPE OF LABOR'S.
PERHAPS NOT THE FOCUS OF OF THE
UNION HALLS.
.
BUT THAT BEING SAID.
AYE AYE YOU RESPECT AND I'M
ENCOURAGED THAT THEY BUY HELP US
FILL THAT GAP BUT IT IT HAS BEEN.
.
IT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR US.
THE.
.
THE CHARACTER OF THAT TYPE OF
LABOR THAT WERE GOING TO NEED
THOUGH IS GOING TO SHIFT TOWARDS
THE MORE SKILLED TRADES AS WE
MOVE INTO THE RECONSTRUCTION
PHASE SO AGAIN IN OF THE.
AT LEAST AT LEAST WITHIN THE
SAMPLE SET THAT OUR CLIENTS
REPRESENT.
.
TO THE THE THE HEAVY CLEAN UP
PHASES SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE
ACROSS MOST OF THOSE PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON. AND WE
ARE NOW.
LOOKING FORWARD TO REBUILDING.
AND SO WE WILL BE LOOKING FOR.
HIGHER STILL TRAYS WITH THE.
VIVID DEFROSTER OF
SUBCONTRACTORS
IN THE REGION.
.
BUT THEY THAT THERE'S THERE'S
LITTLE DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
THEY.
DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
DEAL WITH THE COMING SURGE OF
WORK AND SO YOU KNOW WHEN THE
WHEN THE MAPPING IS COMPLETE.
AND WHEN THE.
PERMITTING A FLOODGATE CAN CAN
THEREFORE OPEN.
SO TO SPEAK REALLY SEE.
WAVE OF WORK COMING IN THAT AND.
AND AND A REAL PROBLEM AROUND
LABOR AVAILABILITY EQUIPMENT
AVAILABILITY.
AT AND I THINK MATERIALS WERE
REALLY REALLY PRIMARILY FOCUS ON
LABOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
BEFORE WE CLOSE.
I WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
TESTING ABOUT PATRICK AND
CALENDAR FROM THE ASHES
UP AND UP FROM THE ASHES IS A
COALITION OF ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED. FIRE AND MUCH LIKE
VICTIMS BOTH FROM THE NORTH BAY
FIRES AND FROM VENTURA SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. DAHLE ALSO
INCLUDES MANY THE LAW FIRMS THAT
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THAT
INCLUDING THE LAW FIRM THAT
REPRESENTS CITY OF SANTA ROSA
CINEMA COUNTY. VENTURA. NAPA
COUNTY AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
SO UP VERY QUICKLY MY WIFE AND I
WERE FIRE VICTIMS.
DUTIES PRESIDENTS NAM STATE
UNIVERSITY ARE STORIES BEEN
PRETTY WELL DISCUSSED.
WE WOKE UP AT FOUR O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING TO OCCUR THE HOUSE
ON FIRE. ESSENTIALLY THE SMOKE
ALARM SAVED OUR LIVES WE RAN OUT
HAD A RUN ABOUT EIGHT TENTHS OF
A MILE. BOXER SHORTS NO.
CLASSES JUDY IN A ROBE INTO OCT
DUTY FIREMAN SAVED OUR LIVES
SOLAR SYSTEM CHANGES FRANKLY I
WOULD JUST TAKE A POLICE CAR
JUST SAY GET OUT NOW. STEP LIKE
THAT BUT WE HAD CELL PHONES AND
ALL THAT THEY'D IN ALERT.
.
AND IF A UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT
LOBBYISTS IS HAVING A TOUGH TIME
TO MOVE FIVE TIMES.
WE'VE HAD A TOUGH TIME PLAN IN
PLACE TO RENT. AND I ONE EVEN
TELL YOU WHAT WE'RE PAYING THE
GALA GENE THAT'S GONE ON WITH
THE NET SO THAT NOT NOT ONE A
YEAR FORTY FOUR BILLS. BUT
CERTAINLY AN ISSUE THAT TAKES
PLACE IN THIS AS WELL.
WE ARE SUBSTANTIALLY APART WITH
OUR INSURANCE COMPANY AGAIN.
IF YOU'RE FROM COPY PARKING A
RENTER AND NO INSURANCE.
BUT THOSE TWO CONTRACTORS SAY
NURTURANCE COMPANIES BUT VERY
QUICKLY.
AS YOU GO THROUGH.
IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER TWO
THIRDS OF VICTIMS ARE
UNDERINSURED.
SELLERS NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
VICTIMS
BETWEEN BUSINESSES AND ANNOUNCE
BETWEEN THE FOUR OR FIVE
COUNTIES TWO THIRDS ARE
UNDERINSURED.
UNITED POLICY SAYS THE AVERAGE
IS THREE A THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT'S ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
IT WILL MATTER WHETHER THEY
REBUILD MOVE WHETHER THEY'D WE
CAN HIRE THE CONSTRUCTION LABORS.
IF YOU CHANGE.
AS THE UTILITIES PROPOSING
INVERSE CONDEMNATION.
HAS BEEN PROPOSED SPECIFICALLY.
THEN IT'S IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE
DON'T GET THAT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION SO WE WANT TO QUICKLY
RESTORE THIS LET'S KEEP THE
CURRENT LIABILITY STANDARDS AS
THEY ARE. WITHIN IT.
BUT THE OTHER POINT THAT THEY'RE
NOT AND I'VE LEARNED THIS FROM
THE LAWYERS OF INVOLVING THESE
FIRES.
IS THE BEST WAY IS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW FIRES OR MUDSLIDES ARE
CREATED.
AND.
IF YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THEN
THERE ARE WAY SAN DIEGO ELECTRIC
FROM THE CEDAR FIRE AS WAS
MENTIONED LARGE ITS LESSON. FROM
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THEY REPLACE
POLLS THAT PUT METAL POLES AND
THE PUT THE BLOCKERS AND THEY
TOOK THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
THAT HAD WE NOT ONE DISASTER.
TWO THIRDS OF FIRES ARE CAUSED
BY UTILITIES SO WE CAN LEARN
FROM THAT TAKE ONE OF YOUR BILLS
WITHIN THAT. PUT THE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE DONE MEASURE IT
WHETHER IT'S CAL FIRE. WERE TOLD
CAL FIRE SHOULD HAVE ITS REPORT
DONE ABOUT A MONTH. THAT WE
THINK THOSE ARE WAYS TO ADDRESS
IT.
WHETHER THE STATE GENERAL FUND
HELPS SET SANTA ROSA GENERAL'S
THE SCHOOLS ARE ALSO DAMAGED
SONOMA STATE. THAT'S A WAY TO
KIND IMMEDIATELY TAKE CARE OF
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES THAT WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION.
BUT WE'RE HERE JUST TO MAKE SURE
WANNA WORK WITH YOU IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY WE ARE VICTIMS
AND WE WANT TO MAKE HELP YOU IN
A WAY AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN AMAZING
DISCUSSION. IS COMPLICATED MANY
VARIABLES WITHIN IT WITH BOARDED
SCOTT WORKING WITH.
AND FREQUENT QUESTION A QUESTION.
YOU MENTIONED CAO GENE BECAUSE
THAT IS SOMETHING WE ARE WORKING
ON WHAT KIND OF GET WHAT DO YOU.
ARE YOU TIME THAT RANK COUNTING.
WELL I THINK.
I THINK ANY YOU KNOW SUPERVISOR
GORE I THINK STRESSED A LOT BY
THE WAY.
CITY OF SANTA ROSA SONOMA COUNTY
FEMA'S BEEN FANTASTIC.
WITH AND I JUST WANNA.
.
SO THEY HAVE OF WHAT IS TO TEN
PERCENT PROVISION IT'S EITHER
COUNTY OR CITY AS WELL. A WITHIN
IT. AND THEY'VE GOT THE DIEGO ON
IT AND ARE MEASURING THAT.
SO IN OUR CASE OBVIOUSLY WE
NEEDED A PRESIDENT'S
ENTERTAINMENT WEIRD A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
SITUATION.
SO WHATPEOPLE ARE DOING IS
THEY'RE BASICALLY SAYING EXACTLY
RIGHT INSURANCE COMPANIES WILL
PAY THIS.
JUDY WE LOVE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RENT YOUR HOUSE OUR HOUSE TO YOU
WE JUST LOVE YOU TO BE THERE FOR.
I'D LIKE TO TALK A THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOR TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH HOW JEAN THAT'S TAKEN PLACE AS
WELL ALONG WITH THE FOUR RUNNER
COPY PARK. WHERE THE WORK THAT'S
COME IN AND IS TRYING TO DO? AND
I DON'T KNOW I I WOULD TURN JUST
THE OUR CITY COUNCILMEN AND
SUPERVISOR AND CITY MANAGERS
WHETHER THERE'S A STATE POLICY
ON THIS. BUT.
IT JUST CAP
PEOPLE ARE GONNA IMMEDIATELY GO
INTO IT AND TAKE ADVANTAGE AND
MANY PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE FACT THAT WE ACTUALLY WE
NEED THE STATE. TO BE A A FROM
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE RENT CONTROL
FAIL AT THE BALLOT A LESS THAN A
YEAR AGO IT SO FOR ONE YEAR WE
ARE NOT AS A BODY ALLOWED TO DO
ANYTHING SUBSTANTIVELY SOMEWHERE
TO RENT CONTROL. IN OUR
JURISDICTION SO WE'VE BEEN
RELIANT ON THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
DECLARATION AND ON WHAT YOU'VE
DONE FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
PIGGYBACK TO TRY TO LIMIT SOME
OF THAT PRICE GOUGING THAT'S
GONE ON.
AND WORK I'M WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE D. A. ON ON THIS ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE SO. I'M
HERE AND THE WOMEN WOULD AND
THAT'S IT WAS.
WE HEAR WE HEAR YOU WE WERE
CONCERNED PER CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AS WELL. AND I KNOW THERE'S
SOME BUDGET REQUEST FROM THE US
SONOMA COUNTY AND CITY OF SANTA
ROSA AND CITY SCHOOLS AND SONOMA
STATEMENT. YOU KNOW THE BUDGET
IN ITS STUFF CAN COME MAN
QUICKLY TO SOME THAT'S GOING TO
GO TO HOUSING.
THANK YOU IT IF IF I COULD JUST
AS A A QUICK THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO CRASH THE THE
PANEL TODAY.
HAS APPEARED. REPRESENTING THE
CITY IN MAKING SURE THAT. WE
HAVE A LOT THAT WE'VE LEARNED IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SHARE THAT.
THERE WAS ONE COMMENT THAT WAS
MADE THAT I REALLY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IF I COULD CHALLENGE
THIS ENTITY UP MISTER THOMPSON
MENTION PRETTY EARLY ON. AYE
SUMI THOMPSON ADMITS IT PRETTY
EARLY ON THAT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IN SANTA ROSA IS.
AN INSURANCE SYSTEM THAT SET UP
FOR ONE INDIVIDUAL TO LOSE THEIR
HOME. AND THAT OUR.
MY CONSTITUENTS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE BEEN ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT KNOW HOW PERSONALLY
GETS. ARE NOT EQUIPPED AND DON'T
HAVE THE TOOLS TO DEAL WITH
MASSIVE.
ECONOMIC SHIFTS IN THE SYSTEM
SO THE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON AVERAGE THAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE UNDER
INSURED IF THEY HAD LOST THEIR
HOMES ONLY. THEY WOULD BE MORE
THAN MORE LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
REBUILD BUT WHEN YOU SEE A
TWENTY PERCENT SHIFT IN THE COST
OF LABOR THE TEN PERCENT SHIFT
IN THE COST OF MATERIALS. THE
WAY THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR
INSURANCE STRUCTURE DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR ANY OF THAT.
THE WAY THAT MY CONSTITUENTS
HAVE TO ITEMIZE THEIR DEDUCTIONS.
IN ORDER TO BE PAID OUT THAT'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT DRAIN AT THE
CHAIR HAS A FANTASTIC BILL
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO REBUILD THEIR
HOMES USING THEIR INSURANCE
DOLLARS. ON ANOTHER LOT THAT
HASN'T BEEN CONTEMPLATED BEFORE
AND WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT
BECAUSE OF THE SCOPE AND THE
SCALE OF WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
IS SO BIG. THAT TWO YEAR RULE
FOR INSURANCE TO REBUILD IS ALSO
A BIG HINDRANCE
SO YOU MENTIONED THAT. YEAH YEAH
EXACTLY AT YOU MENTION THERE'S
THE FORTY FOUR BILLS THAT MIGHT
NOT BE INCLUDING THE SENATE I
THINK LAST WE HEARD FROM THAT
THE TRACKING THERE'S OVER
SEVENTY BILLS. A LOT OF THEM
DEALING WITH THE INSURANCE
ISSUES AS I'D REALLY I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF YOU WHO ARE WORKING
ON THAT ISSUE AND REALLY
HIGHLIGHT THAT THAT'S WHERE OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE STRUGGLING NOW.
WE'VE MOSTLY GOTTEN OUT OF THEIR
WAY WE PRODUCE PERMIT FEES
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN'T ALLOW
THEM TO REBUILD BUT EIGHTY
PERCENT HAVE NOT SETTLED WITH
THEIR INSURANCE YET. THAT THAT'S
WHERE THE FOCUS NEEDS TO BE FOR
REFORM. THE OTHERS WANT AYE
HITTERS ONE PIECE OF THE
PANELISTS AND
YEAH I. UP UNTIL IT.
CHAIRMAN LEVINE TELL MADE UP TO
THIS ONE PIECE OF THIS YOU KNOW
THAT WE THAT WE HAVEN'T SO I
CAREFULLY CALCULATED RELOCATION
EXPENSE THREE YEARS.
AND WE HAD ENOUGH TO DO IT. BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS PEOPLE ARE
CALCULATING FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS
OR TWO YEARS AND IRAN OUT A
RELOCATION SO EVEN IF WE
EXTENDED THE FOR YEARS WHICH YOU
SHOULD DO. CRITICAL AND STUFF
LIKE THAT YOU CAN HELP PEOPLE
GONNA RUN OUT OF THE RELOCATION
EXPENSE OF TWO YEARS AND I'M NOT
SURE. WHAT WE DO ABOUT THAT?
CAN.
ALSO JUST MAKE ONE QUICK FINAL
COMMENT WHICH I MIGHT LOOK WAS
GOING TO SAY THIS EARLIER BUT IT
REALLY STRUCK HOME WHEN I SAW
THE PICTURES FROM SANTA BARBARA
AND THAT. HIS YOU KNOW FROM A
FROM A WATERSHED IN AND WE
TALKED ABOUT FORCE HELP THAT ONE
OF THEM THE CONCERNS ON THE KEYS
ME UP A LOT. ESPECIALLY IN THE
WINTER IS THE FACT THAT MANY OF
THE SYSTEMS WE HAVE LIKE DEBRIS.
BASINS OR FLOOD CONTROL CHANNELS
LIKE A SAID THEY'VE BEEN
DESIGNED FOR WORLD THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS.
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE THIS IN
THIS NEW NORMAL AND. THE ROOF
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO ENCOURAGE.
HERE ASSEMBLY HERE AT THIS THIS
COMMITTEE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
FINDING WAYS TO BOTH INTEGRATE
FLOOD CONTROL SYSTEMS AND FIRE
PROTECTION SYSTEMS TOGETHER
THERE'S AWAY WITH WATERSHED
HEALTH. WHAT I'M FORCED
MANAGEMENT?
DEBRIS PACE AND ALL OF THAT TO
TO LOOK AT THAT AND TO AND TO
POTENTIALLY IN ON JAMES AND I
TALKED ABOUT THIS EARLIER. WE
ARE TO HAVE A FRAMEWORK UNDER
THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS HAD BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO THE STATE. AND
POTENTIALLY USING THAT THOSE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES IN THE
NORTH COAST WE HAVE THE NORTH
COAST RESOURCE PARTNERSHIP USING
THOSE STRUCTURES THAT GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE THAT'S BEEN WORKING
REALLY WELL. AS A WAY TO LOOK AT
THIS LONGER TERM RESILIENCE
LONGER TERM PROTECTION OF THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT I THINK ARE.
ARE ARE ALL VERY VULNERABLE
YOU'RE GONNA BE VULNERABLE NOT
JUST FOR THREE TO FIVE YEARS
IT'S.
IT'S THE NEW NORMAL ITSELF.
THANKS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING THANK ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR PARTICIPATING I
THINK AND WE HAVE HAD ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AND.
IN APPRECIATION I THINK ALSO
FOR EACH OTHER FOR WHAT EVERYONE
HAS LEARNED WHAT WE BROUGHT TO
THE TABLE. AND NO ONE HAS
HESITATED TO PICK UP THE PHONE
SEND A TEXT MESSAGE TO BETTER
LEARN IT SOUNDS LIKE AT THE CITY
AND COUNTY LEVELS THAT'S
HAPPENING AS WELL. AYE I THINK
YOU'VE GIVEN US ALL I'M MORE.
IT INFORMATION IT'S ADDED TO
WHAT WE KNOW ON BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS YOU HAVE
MENTIONED THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
STILL GOING SO LONG AS THESE
BILLS GO THROUGH THE PROCESS IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WE WILL BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION. AND I
THINK WHAT YOU'VE ALL
CONTRIBUTED AND IT IS IS A GREAT
DEAL UP TO THIS CONVERSATION I'M
ALSO CLEAR THAT THE SAKE OF
CONVERSATION SHOULD NOT AND HERE.
I HAD THAT IT NEEDS TO CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN BECAUSE.
EVERY TIME I THINK I KNOW WHAT I
MEAN WE ARE HAVE AND LIKE ONE
MORE THING COMING UP WHAT I
THOUGHT WE FIXED THAT SOMEWHERE
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
TO HAVE THE SPACE AND I WANNA.
AT ESPECIALLY THINK UP MY CO
CHAIR AT ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
WHO YOU KNOW BROUGHT TOGETHER
AND THE GROUP I HAVE FOR
BRINGING US TOGETHER AND?
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
WOULD ANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
WANNA MAKE ANY COMMENTS.
I JUST WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT
WE'RE NOT DONE RENO THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK AND I'LL NEVER
FORGET WHEN THEY HAVE THE
OAKLAND FIRES. AND PEOPLE THAT
SUMS STUMP IS SOMETHING TO
CHANGE POLICY AND THEN IT KIND
OF WENT AWAY. AND WE'RE HERE WE
HAVE TO BE HERE FOR THE LONG
HAUL WE CAN'T FORGET SO.
I A WILL COMMIT TO YOU AND I
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU BEFORE NOT
EVERYONE OF US TO YOU BEFORE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WE
HAVE A LOT MORE TO DO WE'RE
GONNA. TRY TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS AND WE MIGHT HAVE TO
TWEAK IT FOR THE NEXT FIVE OR
TEN YEARS BLESSED TO AN ATTACK.
.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN WE GOT
THROUGH OCTOBER.
I HAD NEVER CONTEMPLATED THAT
THE FIRE SEASON WAS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
OR THAT.
DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
THE DISASTERS THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD EXPERIENCE A CALIFORNIANS
WOULD EXPERIENCE WOULD BE.
THAT THE TYPES OF DISASTERS
THAT WE ENDED UP HAVING LATER ON
IN THE YEAR.
AND.
IT AND.
IT WAS HORRIFYING WHEN THOSE
FIRES BEGAN AGAIN IN DECEMBER
THINKING WOULD.
WE DID NOT GET THROUGH THIS THIS
ISN'T OVER BY NOW.
AND DIE AND SO YOU KNOW I'M
GRATEFUL.
.
THAT DESPITE THAT WE HAD THESE
SHARED EXPERIENCES I'M GRATEFUL
THAT LAWMAKERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. AND THERE ARE MANY MORE
THAN JUST THE THE FIVE OF US
HERE.
.
ARE ENGAGED ON THIS.
IT'S BE IT GOES BEYOND THE MAY
REVISE AND WE HAVE A BUDGET TO
PASS
YOU PROBABLY WANT TO SEE A FEW
THINGS CHANGED AND IMPROVED.
AN ADDED.
AND ALSO HOW DO WE PREPARE.
NOT JUST OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
THAT SUFFERED SO MUCH BUT ALSO
SOME THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
THAT CAN.
UNFORTUNATELY SUFFER THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE AND THAT WE ARE.
AWAKENED TO THE US THAT WE'VE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
TO PREVENT.
MORE SUFFERING TO HAPPEN ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND I I THINK A COMMITMENT FROM
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE CREATION OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE TO SEE THIS
THROUGH ITS NOT JUST A FIRE THAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR. IT'S NOT
JUST A NATURAL DISASTER THAT
OCCURRED IN DECEMBER IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABOUT WORKING TOGETHER AS
COLLEAGUES TO MAKE SURE IS A
PART OF POLICY MAKING IN A PART
OF BUDGET PRIORITIES. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE FOR A LONG TIME TO
COME I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR MY CO
CHAIR. IN HER LEADERSHIP OF THIS
AS WELL ALONG WITH ALL OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS AFTER THAT
SUSTAINED COMMITMENT. AND OF
COURSE THANK YOU TO THE
PANELISTS FOR HELPING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO GO.
WELL EQUIPPED AND WELL ARMED TO
OUR COLLEAGUES IN TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE THE
CASE FOR WHY ARE WE NEED TO
PREPARE AND ALSO INVEST IN OUR
RECOVERY TO BE MORE RESILIENT.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH.
YES MISTER ABOUT SORRY YEAH
SORRY JUST AS YOU'RE SITTING
THERE THINKING AND TALK OR I I
pI'M PIPE ACTUALLY REALLY
ENCOURAGED. BY THE MAY REVISE.
THE GOVERNOR BRING FORWARD
POTENTIALLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX MILLION OR SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AROUND FORESTRY
WHILE AND MANAGEMENT CAREER
THAT'S A. BIG DEAL.
AND.
AND SO AS WE AS WE GRAPPLE WITH
WHAT WE KNOW IS IS AN EVER
CHANGING LANDSCAPE. THAT'S A
REALLY REALLY BIG DEAL FOR US
AND SO.
.
WE'RE RIGHT.
RIGHT YEAH FRIDAY WAS A VERY
GOOD DAY.
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BANKRUPTCY
INSOLVENCY PRETTY MUCH YEAH
BETWEEN BACK CATALOG.
IT IS IT'S A LOT LIKE YOU KNOW
THE ARGUMENT IF YOU KNOW WHERE
YOU KNOW THEIR THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THERE ARE
TWO AND FIFTY PERCENT OF NORMAL
FOR FOR THE HOTELS IN CINEMA
COUNTY. AND YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S THE CASE
MOVING FORWARD FOR EVEN THE
STATE INVESTMENT AS WELL BUT
IT'S. IT'S NICE TO.
TO KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN HURT BUT.
YEAH WE SAW OUR WORK OUT FOR US.
YEAH THANK YOU TO MAKE IT OUT SO
MUCH IT DOES.
YOU HAVE GOOD FOR ME.
YEAH